[Music]
e
for
[Music]
o
a
[Music]
the
h
[Music]
oh
day two of The Showdown in St Louis saw
the players play Fisher random and it
was caruana who drew first blood winning
the first game of the match but the last
laugh went to Hikaru Nakamura after he
won the next two games and now takes a
one-point lead in the match coming into
today but the next matchup was even more
fiery GM how you fun after losing two
games yesterday against Nei stormed back
winning three in a row dominating the
match and now she has the lead going
into day three coming up next here The
Showdown in St
[Music]
Louis
hello and we are back at the showdown in
St Louis here at the capital of Chess in
America at the St Louis chess club we've
got rapid chess for you guys today
Nakamura Carana Nei vers Hoon um I
expect another very exciting day of jazz
yeah we saw so many decisive games
yesterday in the Fisher random I wonder
if the players are recovered from that
day yesterday but good to see you Jen
it's lovely to be here as always yeah
I'm Jennifer shahadi I'm here with yaser
Saran and we are very excited to bring
you more from St Louis let's take a look
at the standing so far for those of you
who haven't been following well we've
got Nakamura with a three and 1 half
lead two and a halfers at carolana so
Naka leads by one point they drew in the
bask chest but in the Fisher random not
that surprising it's one of nakamura's
favorite forms of chest as he took a
one-point
lead now more surprises in Nei versus
hoyon we didn't expect um Nei to come
out just smashing in the bass chest he
won two games and remember that he's
actually studying at Stanford so he's
been taking a break from professional
Jaz right meanwhile yon rebounded in in
such wonderful fashion yesterday getting
three and a half out of four and not
just because Negi screwed up she played
brilliantly indeed she was dominant in
the games of yesterday and all of her
victories were really kind of model
performances very impressive play uh
especially with it back to the wall
that's right and uh let's take a look at
what we're going to see more of today
well we've got rapid chass but actually
rapid rapid chass if you will because
it's game 15 with a 10-second increment
and we're going to see four rounds of
that so hold on um tight this is going
to be a really really fun ride tomorrow
we have Blitz eight games of the blitz
both matches and that'll be game three
with a two second increment so that
really will flash flash very quickly and
we've got Grandmaster morrice Ashley
with a summary on the match so far and
what do he expects from
today well we often talk about in sports
lead changes uh we see it of course in
the NBA all the time one of my favorite
sports of basketball but in these
matches we've seen the same Fabiano car
took the lead in Fisher random only to
see himself overturned by Nakamura as he
won two games in a row things were even
more Topsy Turvy in the other match as
Nei stormed out to a two-point lead only
to see haifan charge back with three
victories so more of the same today for
sure when we asked Fabiano Carana about
yesterday's Fisher random this is what
he had to say he said first of all it's
stressful I said well is it the time or
the position and he replied it's taking
us hundreds of years to understand just
the normal starting positions in chess
so I don't think an extra 10 or 15
minutes is going to help me over the
board he explained why he wasn't sitting
at the board trying to figure out these
crazy positions that were in front of
him well there is more craziness to
expect today rapid chess always breeds a
ton of excitement I'm looking forward to
round three here of The Showdown in St
Louis thank you Maurice indeed and we
are going to have some really great
games today I really feel that the
players are in a combative mood as we've
seen throughout all the rounds well Naka
thinks that today is K's best chance yes
he mentioned that in the interview yeah
that he thinks the the the weirdness of
the Fisher random in the bass chest
gives him an edge of course um Nakamura
renowned Blitz player but then in Rapid
that's the closest to real chats where
he and caran are obviously neck and neck
exactly he thought that the that in this
form of of chess the rapid chess where
uh Fabby had his best chances and he
really really considered himself and
rightfully so a favorite in the blitz
right I mean there's no uh trash talking
there just look at the scoreboard look
at the scoreboard and that's the most
impressive thing I mean I think one of
the reasons nakur has calmed down in
recent years is I mean he doesn't have
to do any kind of uh any bragging right
his resols are really speaking for
exactly well and he had been in the
world's top 10 for quite a number of
years and he had good results and poor
result results uh mix but he really
seems to me in especially in the last
let's say 24 months that he's kicked
himself in a higher gear and he had
become the world's number two he fell
back just a little most recently but he
is really impressive and as we get ready
for March and the candidates uh both of
these players have made it very clear
their ambition is to become Challenger
to Magnus Carlson and they both have a
shot and they're both a candidates and
that's going to be really exciting for
us absolutely and uh who do you think
think has a better chance to uh make it
through yeah uh just the player who's in
sparkling form that's going to decide I
mean you just put all the pass behind
you and it's uh a very long tournament
first of all as 13 Rounds so uh the
player who just plays consistently
throughout is going to succeed now I
it's going to have a lot to do with
preparation as well I mean they're
bringing their they're bringing their
big gun one I mean you really need a a
lot of very uh good preparation and
there's nothing else to save it for I
you saving it for Magnus who doesn't
even play Theory most of the time no
this is it I mean if you've got
something High lurking there in your in
your chest base you're going to play it
exactly I got to say that's not an
answer though yeah you got to commit put
a player on the line I I'll be the first
to say I think Nakamura frankly he is
looks like the hungriest player on the
circuit uh he is got a transformation
that's happened in his game he's playing
a lot more solidly a lot more like if
he's not going to try to risk anything
as we see haifan coming to the playing
Hall I just I really feel like
nakamura's Time Has Come uh he he has a
lot to prove and I believe he's the
hungriest if you look to all the players
playing in the candidates I think
Nakamura is the hungriest player of all
right now the most desperate to try to
prove that he belongs as the opportunity
to his opportunity to win or at least
challenge Magnus now as far as the
numbers between him and Magnus m not the
greatest he's got a long way to go to
even come close to an even score against
Magnus and there he is walking in the
fourth time US champ the reigning champ
as of
today and again I just think he's the
hung He's the hottest player on the
circuit also he's won so many
tournaments this year jalter he won Zur
he won in Switzerland as well was it
Zurich won he also won the millionaire
chess open he's just hungry he he just
looks like a person who's com into his
own seems very confident that he belongs
now uh maybe number two maybe if he
could show it number
one well I've always been a huge
Nakamura fan because I just love the way
he plays chess but I I'm trying to come
up with an argument for Fabby and I
think that preparation is a big one Fab
is very well known for being a super
hard work and having great preparation
well it all came into uh Crystal Clear
uh in the 2014 SFI cup with that seven
and he won won maybe two G two games I'm
going to say literally with great
opening preparation and so yes that
could that's going to be key can we both
win no only one Challenger two matches
against Magnus I like that right like
well you want Magnus to play bass chess
or something no no we yeah that would be
fun I mean if we if if we had a chance
to see Nakamura Carlson and carolana
Carlson I would like to see both of
those matches I mean Carlson would would
uh be likely to go down to at least one
of them and we'd have our American World
Champion well we do see the players have
arrived for today's matches
Hogan and probably Maran Nei and we've
also got carolana
and hikaro hikaro they're they're all
they're all ready to to get this the
party started yes and the r and again I
just have to say that I think it's just
incredible what hoan did uh losing uh
two games in a match uh to start and
then coming back storming back with
three in a row that's really really
remarkable and it it's always been the
true sign of a champion in my eyes how
they deal with their losses because that
can be very very difficult as we all
know uh a loss can be very painful and
this young lady has really impressed me
uh greatly with three wins that she got
yesterday yeah I agree I mean mental
game is so important that's why you see
people just mental toughness that's
right they call it grit resilience I was
reading uh you know there's a lot of
people and researchers who talk about
how that's the most important quality to
being successful not just in chess but
really in anything in life um there's a
good Ted Talk on that about grit and I
was reading another article by an
entrepreneur who was giving his like top
10 um somebody who invested in Uber and
like they did really really well and he
was giving his top 10 traits of a
champion well a a very uccessful
entrepreneur and uh resilience was
number one interesting and well uh
nakamura's resilience too okay he had
slipped and he was behind in the match
and he came back with back-to-back
victories and he did not press uh in the
fourth game and uh he was just happy to
take his one-point lead in today's rapid
chess uh format and we've got Tony Rich
with uh today's intro and roll
welcome to day three of the 2015
showdown in St Louis the action is
really heating up in the match between a
Nakamura and Fabiano caruana hikaro
leech two and a half three and a half
and the match between hauan and Par Nei
hauan leads the match three and a half 2
and a half today is rapid chess with a
Time control of game in 15 minutes with
a 10-second increment we will be
following the Fay uh rapid play rules of
Chess uh some quick notes on that uh
please remember that you must castle
with only one hand uh Pawn promotion
must be completed uh including replacing
the piece uh the pawn on the board um
failing to do so and leaving the pawn on
the last Rank and hitting your clock is
the same as making an illegal move and
an illegal move for is a forfeit in
Rapid
chess we'll play four rounds today with
colors alternating we'll have a 10 to 15
minute break in between
rounds some reminders for the spectators
uh flash photography is allowed for the
first 10 minutes after that you can
still take pictures just no flash please
um also uh since we have a nice small
room here uh noise is a big concern so
please make sure that you're um quiet no
talking in this room the players aren't
allowed to talk to anybody during their
games anyway
um uh tomorrow will be rapid chess we'll
have eight rounds time control 3 minutes
plus 2
seconds unless we have any questions
from the players
I want to wish everybody the very best
of luck you may
begin and we're getting started and of
course Nakamura can play anything in the
first move and he shows that B2 B3 B3
immediately responding with G6 okay
Bishop
B2 Knight
F6 now this is actually a uh just a a
moment I remember a game of anat carop
and Walter Brown where there was a
capture on F6 and C4 no don't take away
the bishop y white was looking to to
plant a knight on D5 but uh that was not
hikaru's Choice instead hikaro I believe
played the move E2 E4 taking advantage
of the fact that the Knight of course is
pinned and that pawn on e4 cannot be
captured because of the Rook is hanging
that's right much love for the Bishops
by nakur and I believe we have D6 on the
board and by the way uh we' got a fun
battle in store as well and Nei Eon as
that looks like it's headed towards a
sicilian let me just uh um okay it
dipped a little bit in its fun potion
but this could also be quite yeah it
could be quite interesting as well maroy
Mary V here by Nei with pawns on C4 and
E4 he's about to follow up with D2 D4 a
departure from his uh earlier game where
he played a more traditional Sicilian
against Eon and she played the dragon
and I guess he wasn't so thrilled with
the outcome right although that was
different because she did play A6 so
it's not like he had a he had a path to
repeating that line well it's but didn't
he get a good position there he won and
he got a good position as well exactly
he did and he was actually very well
prepared um not a formation that you'll
see every day uh it looks like a perk of
sorts there's this beautiful Central
Pawn Duo on D4 and E4 but the double Fe
and cadow Bishop
uh that's that's different that's
different in the game between he Carl
and Faby let it looks like it's turned
into a maroxy bind on both boards now uh
after these last couple of moves takes
on C5 check Queen D2 and queen C5 and C4
clamping down and in this case the
double fing kto for the maroxy bind not
the case yet anyway we're waiting to see
a move like D4 happen on the other board
and then we would see a maroxy bind as
as well there but standard position in
front of us in the maroxy bind classical
play well the structure of the maroxy
bind has always been kind of irritating
for me when I'm playing on the black
side against it because it's uh very
hard to get active play it is so this
Knight can often find itself on D5 and a
lot of times you're you're stuck in a
situation where if you leave it there
it's not fun and if you capture it
you're slightly worse right Knight takes
D5 e takes D5 and sometimes the pawn on
E7 can be uh painfully awkward to defend
uh having said that with the bishop
already on G2 often times black is
searching for his own counterplay based
on A6 and B5 and just the fact that the
bishop is not adding lending its weight
to stopping B5 makes me think that
that's the uh most natural source of
counterplay for for Fabby in this
position is to play for B5 quickly alth
your queen is is a little bit funny on C
that could that actually could be a
negative because it can get kind of
hassled by moves like Knight A4 for if
for instance if you play A6 sometimes
we'll be able to stick that in and annoy
you but uh yeah exactly kind of trying
to hammer on that up
B6 let us the because the time control
by the way uh game 15 with 10 seconds we
do expect a much faster brisk Pace than
we might otherwise see in Rapid chest
that's right did you read my brother's
articles on slow chess no I didn't what
did Greg have to say a queen
D4 you said that slow chess should die
oh my um he just he it was just an
article about how like if somebody
invented chess now wow they'd be a real
genius for one thing because it took you
know so many centuries
of yes exactly to create this great game
but um if they did that they they would
kind of go with the starting point of
making it uh quicker because of in order
to compete with like video games games
and stuff like that yeah um or anything
I mean TV video games like basically
anything that people do um they would
almost always want to do it faster so
it's kind of interesting although uh the
counter arguments is that like just like
novels people some people actually like
chess because it's an antidote to
everything else that they
do high speed and it's just the how our
society has grown from you know baths to
showers and you were just moving so much
quicker in our lives and um well for me
I I love classical chess I the beauty
the appreciation of the players putting
in so much hard work over the board and
finding something creative uh speaking
of creative uh intriguing move here by
uh Fabiano he played Queen D4 offering
the trade of Queens normally speaking um
it's in Black's interest is Black's
Queen usually in a moroy bind doesn't
have um a safe Square sometimes in a
maroy bind you can see that the queen
comes over here to A5 and from A5 uh
black is usually happy to trade Queens
when White's Knight moves but white is
never really forced to play Knight D5
and sometimes the queen on A5 is just
simply misplaced other times this queen
sometimes comes over to the over here to
H5 to try to be able to play Bishop H3
and such formations but you always have
to be careful for Knight E2 Knight F4 so
basically what Fabiana said is I've got
a problem with my queen I don't know
what to do with it let's trade him off
so he's played the move Queen D2 and let
me get get caught up to
date we do have uh a trade so after
Queen D4 Queen takes D4 by hikaro and
that's something that you don't see very
often in a u maroy hassles on the queen
side uh he does uh gain a nice Tempo
however against the Knight on D4 the
Knight dropped back to E6 we have H2 H3
stopping any ideas like Knight G4 and we
have Knight C5 Maurice your
thoughts well that game certainly is a
lot more solid structure for black and
looks like they're going to go into a
more or less evish end game certainly
white has a bit of space with that pawn
on e4 and C4 that Moro C buying position
but another one that is in a completely
different vein is the game that's going
on between haifan and pan Nei where the
maroxy bind is in full effect tons of
space for white let's take a look at how
the game proceed after he did play D4
again we see the pawns on e4 and C4 in
the position Bishop to B7 and now the
move castles and after Knight F6
attacking this Pawn F3 and D6 and kg
position for black the Hedgehog as it's
called the Hedgehog setup Bishop to E3
Bishop to E7 and queen D2 all standard
moves and after these couple of moves
developing pieces now all the pieces
have moved everyone's got their station
Nei essayed the move B4 at this moment
B4 getting more space on this side the
Knight not being able to go to the C5
Square the way it is right now in the
game with Carana and Nakamura the pawn
on B4 gaining some space and after the
move Queen back to B8 typical maneuver
in the Hedgehog now A3 and look at
White's pawns attempting to hold down
the position but of course there are
evils to having all that space sometimes
you can be chipped Away by some tactical
ideas of B5 and D5 white will have to be
on the lookout for those kind of ideas
sometimes black will put the queen on A8
this bishop sometimes also Maneuvers d8
to C7 so lots of ideas the players no
doubt are familiar with we'll see how
the game proceeds as these two great
Champions here sitting looking for an
option is how you f exactly what does
she need to do to break out of jail
because that space is certainly annoying
to have to deal with thank you Maurice
and again I I I love to hot hedhog as
black when I played uh professionally I
just love this idea of letting your
opponent commit to a um strategy and
being very flexible to be able to
counter it basically what black does
often in the Hedgehog he plays a mov
Rook on f8 to E8 he drops back with his
Bishop either to the f8 square or to the
d8 and C7 Square I believe that the way
that Hui hoi fan has played it so far
she's going to play it in the Fisher
style of Bishop d8 to C7 playing for
okay let me just why the Fisher style is
there a famous game you're referring to
Yes um um ol Anderson Bobby fiser from a
radio match uh let me just make a move
for white so I can show oops is it
Black's Black's turn yes it is uh
what this idea has in mind Bishop C7 so
what black wants to do is play D5 and
then play Bishop takes H2 check opening
up the position against uh Black's King
uh after you play Move Like G3 sometimes
you have this uh Fisher idea of King G8
to h8 it looks a little a little bit uh
paradoxical followed by Rook G8 and
preparing the advance of the pawn to G5
ng4 really very very very uh lots of
cool action yeah yeah it's good stuff I
enjoyed this these these kinds of games
you might turn us around you might turn
me and Maurice around to them Roxy keep
talking about Rook G8
G5 get some fun I've seen that idea
before myself and and I am a I favor the
Hedgehog uh positions as black
absolutely you won a couple of nice
games with the black side and those
thematic ideas are very interesting of
course you could be tortured by the
maroxy as well those are never fun you
don't even want to talk about those kind
of games but that idea of playing for G5
and Swinging all the pieces over
particularly when white is not poised to
take on G5 if if I'm in a different
position here and there's some
excitement happening in the other game
but sometimes white will have the queen
over here on F2 instead
and that will give black the opportunity
to come very quickly with the Advance on
this side as you mentioned y the other
game though we should point out this
game has taken a curious turn uh back
here we saw the maneuver knight6 H3
Knight C5 and after Knight G2 this move
A5 and this move very committal pawn
move even though it looks like maybe one
day you'll push this Pawn to A4 looking
for some kind of counterplay it also
weakens permanently the square B5 and
gives you the impression that Black's
Pawn flexibility has been reduced
dramatically the idea of B5 is no longer
possible with any ease anyway if white
stays clear uh keeps attention anyway
stays alert is what I meant to say to
this push and he played Bishop A3 say I
bet you will not play the move A4 right
now for one thing just dropping a pawn
so and this capture Knight Bishop takes
Knight freezes those light squares
permanently so Knight A6 was played in
response and that prompted Nakamura to
play E5 suddenly so a solid position
suddenly explodes with the Central Pawn
break the bishop gets his long diagonal
and D takes E5 now Bishop takes on E7
and the engines are saying definite
Advantage for white now the move Rook E8
and one of the most critical moves in
all of Chess Bishop takes Knight that
move is a very important exchange I
consider it the most important Exchange
in chess of all the most important why
because after this takes take now the
light squares are all completely weak
this bishop cannot guard light squares
only these two pieces but white has
three pieces that can dominate on the
light squares so black has to be careful
sure black dominates the dark squares
but if that doesn't happen he'll be in
trouble and immediately Nakamura play
the move Knight to E4 in the position
attacking this bishop threatening to go
into D6 hitting this Pawn on this Square
I believe the continuation was Bishop
back to E7 and now the Knight plunked
itself down on the D6 Square we have a
trade on D6 six that has changed the
position also because now the light
Square dominance is somewhat different
the miners match each other but still we
got this nice Bishop on this diagonal
Rook coming to the open file this Knight
will bounce to C3 B5 D or D5 this is
looking very good easy play for Nakamura
at least Karana certainly in a bit of
trouble in this particular position he
may not be out of the wood he may not he
may not be busted but he's not going to
be out of the woods for some time as
this game has just simply
exploded that's right but it it looks
like uh Fabby has just traded off pawns
with the move A4 a A5 A4 right so
obviously if uh if white were to
recapture that pawn um Fabby could play
something like Knight C5 and end up
gaining the pawn and then also
pressurizing the A2 Pawn so instead
Nakamura played Knight to C3 right I was
just going to say I think that uh Hikaru
opened up the position really really
well and that this move A5 followed by
Knight A6 was just mistimed by Fabiano I
think he had to have played Bishop D7 in
that position a little bit too ambitious
with move A5 and now after Knight C3 we
can see it's very easy for white white
intends to Simply double his Rooks on
the defile uh use this Outpost either
for a knight possibly a bishop and don't
forget the Rook could actually swing
over here to B6 and just this bishop on
G2 is a monster uh pressurizing on B7 we
need to figure out how to how to
consolidate and things here as white and
get our our pieces into into the action
because the thing with with black is our
Knight and our Bishop are terrible exact
like our works aren't that bad but I
mean we need to get to figure out
something to do with those pieces the
question is where for the Black Knight
on A6 like I'd love to get it to a D4
perhaps by a C5 E6 cuz then I could also
get in the way of you trying to double
your Rooks and do ugly
things do uh some damage uh Knight C5 in
this position King B2 I like what you're
what you're
suggesting that in case of Knight E6
Rook to D1 pardon me I got to get my
Rook over there uh you could plug up the
position with with your move Knight D4
the problem is this Knight on D4 is
really really good I might play a move
like F2 F4
undermining the knight uh you you do
have to move Knight F5 attacking The
Rook but when I go Rook to d8 don't
forget this beauty this Beauty on um uh
G2 if I ever get to capture that pawn on
B7 I'll have uh hikaro will have two
connected pass pawns and I think that
that will be uh winning very easy play
for Wyatt ESP game and so and K instead
of trying to activate his night
immediately played King to G7 here kind
of getting his King off the back rank
mhm and yet it does seem quite slow yeah
it doesn't solve his problems of how
he's going to connect his Rooks and uh
bring his Bishop into the game the
simple Rook D1 bringing everybody to the
party uh again uh you black would like
to move as Bishop Bishop to E6 but this
bishop takes uh B7 is just uh too
beastly to consider you've got to stop
you got to play some defensive move I'm
I don't want to suggest it but there's a
move like Rook A8 to B8 in order to
develop the bishop but then the whole
operation of A5 A4 opening up the a file
for The Rook is undone well instead it
looks like Knight C5 was played oh
instead of King G7 oh after King G7 King
B2 oh King B2 was played anticipating
Knight C5 and by the way uh setting up a
possibility of Rook A1 that's you'd be
threatening all sorts of nasty things
right yes so that Pro uh
provoked uh Knight C5 and now we're kind
of transposing a little bit into that
position that we looked at a moment ago
if we play Rook to D1 here Knight E6 is
Comfortably stopped with Knight B5 the
Knight takes up a great station so that
Knight D4 is not uh playable Nakamura
chose another path instead he played
Rook well B4 was an option for sure to
calculate what happens in that situation
after night A4 check um but it seems
like all rad to be somewhat better for
white but instead uh instead hikaro
chose Rook D5 and there's a lot of good
news for Nakamura in this position not
only does it seem like every one of his
pieces is stronger than his opponents I
mean if you look if you play that game
right especially now that we're going to
be dislodging this Knight on B6 note
that it can't be held because at B6 we
can simply capture the Knight winning
material the power of that F and shedow
Bishop exactly nice discovered attack so
our Bishop's better our rook's better
our Knight's better but there's a six
piece that we're not even talking about
we also have twice as much time as our
opponent so massive pressure and twice
as much time on the clock Maurice said
do you think Nakamura is is just
massively on top here how can kowana
fight
back well after all you explained I
couldn't disagree with all that I mean
it's this is bad this is horrible and he
has had to play the graveling move night
back to a six it's just all Christmas or
maybe early Thanksgiving at least for
Nakamura this piece is better it can go
to B5 he had to worry about the C7
Square was T night landed here hitting
that square this Pawn is isolated it's a
two-on-one majority already all the
pieces are more active you're just
waiting to figure out when this one will
come into the game and dominate it's
just it's miserable this bishop as soon
as it leads Rook B5 is going to show up
on the board and that Pawn's going to be
dead so what to do I mean just a
horrible position for him almost every
move by the way B4 as you mentioned
earlier was a good shot according to the
engines this Rook can go to A1 it could
go to D1 there's even this idea of
Knight to E4 which looks quite strong
after Bishop to E6 well there's a pawn
hanging here we could take maybe but
what about Rook B5 also in the position
and the pressure is overwhelming it's an
embarrassment of riches and you know
sometimes you look at it you say there's
so many choices the guy might screw up
Nakamura tends to to not screw up I mean
he loves having options and he finds the
most dominant one and man he looks like
the chesher cat right now he's feeling
very comfortable he has a lead on the
clock pressure on the board overwhelming
start to game one and he's just doubled
Rooks in that position he knows it's
it's just so over it's such a big Edge
coming right out of the opening that
move A5 as you mentioned y was the
culprit just a bit too much at asking
from the position and now it seems that
he has moved he's played the move Knight
to B4 in this position Knight to B4 and
that is not going to solve much uh Rook
can go anywhere Rook B5 is an automatic
move here for example where do you put
the knight in that position the Knight
seems like it's trying to head towards
the D4 Square so let's take a look at
this line Rook B5 Knight C6 Knight to E4
and then Knight to D4 but the engines
already calculating something pretty
dangerous with Knight to to D6 really
interesting move the point being that
Knight takes B5 is answered by this
check King to f8 and now Rook to
d8 wow positions getting really crazy
now there's no Clarity in this line
we're going to have to analyze what
these lines mean because after King E7
he wants to play Rook D5 preparing to
take this take this and then hit on this
again wild position but the tactics
seemed to be favoring Nakamura in most
of these lines it did not go that route
let's take a look at the game the way it
did go after Rook to D6 after night B4
he played Rook D6 Rook A6 and Nakamura
traded on A6 so the game is still
Advantage white but the clarity hasn't
been realized just yet but still big
Advantage for white in that game
meantime just a quick peek at the other
game it's still in the opening stages no
matter what the time it always seems
like Nakamura and Fab and Fabby they're
way down in some AME and these guys just
started they just set up set up an
opening position 8 minutes on the clock
fori 7 minutes for Ean so this one will
get really exciting very quickly but for
now just in the opening as the other two
after the trade on A6 Pawn takes on A6
are way deep into some endgame position
where white has a pass Pawn is looking
to try to MK this position home thank
you Maurice and again
uh the the thing about
uh strategic chess it's all about peace
activity and if you look at the position
on the board the black Bishop on C8
hasn't even moved yet better activity
for the White's Rook better activity for
White's bishop and in a nice little way
now that uh this Pawn has gone to the A6
square there's even the idea of White's
King just kind of coming up uh
encroaching up the board against the A6
Pawn later in the end game so certainly
everything go going very swimmingly and
I just wanted to point out the tactic if
the idea of Knight B4 had been to come
back to C6 and to D4 well the idea for
white is that he could
have captured captured and gotten that
type of position that I was mentioning
earlier Jen of two connected pass pawns
and they would be very very Swift in
fact they will be escorted by with the
help of Rook knight and king these two
connected p pawns would have won the
game so that wasn't even uh a
possibility and that was why Fabby
played Rook A6 Maurice a big point in
the other game quickly the move Knight
E5 attacking this Pawn just going back a
couple of moves Queen F2 typical
maneuver we talked about that Queen
shifting to the F2 Square hitting this
pawn and saying well how you going to
defend it and the answer Bishop D7 was
I'm not because I'm hitting your C Pawn
this one weakness of putting the pawn on
B4 if we look at the Nakamura game the
Pawn's on B3 but that dark side of space
when you play A3 B4 in the maroxy is
that C4 becomes a point of contention
and the only way really reasonable to
defend this ball is play Knight D2 the
kind of move you're not really excited
about playing in this position of course
snap off the pawn on B6 is possible
Knight takes C4 is an answer to that
hitting the bishop and hitting the a
pawn as well Bishop takes on C4 doesn't
trouble black at all because of Rook
takes and black is doing quite well so
that maneuver Bishop D7 actually is a
critical moment in the game ignoring the
attack on the pawn one of my favorite
things to see happen I remember a good
friend of mine Willie Johnson he always
said you know it's terrible when you
threaten something and the guy says who
cares I'm ignoring it well in this case
the lady has said yeah you want my B
Pawn you can have it but I'm going to
get a good position from it and the
engines are agreeing this position is
just fine for black how you find
quitting herself quite well coming out
the opening thank you Maurice and uh I
was a little bit surprised here by the
choice of hikaro hiara played Knight E4
very strong move centralizing the knight
uh nothing wrong with this move
whatsoever you even thinking of uh
plunking the Knight down on D6 I again I
found myself attracted to the line of
Rook D6 uh taking up a station and the
idea was that I really did want to go
into this ending where I saw that this
King was going to be so active so very
quickly whereas Black's King uh has no
uh similar attacks on the king side Yaro
went for the move Knight E4 and after
Knight E4 Rook E7 Sid stepping uh the
the fork that could have resulted from
Knight D6 and are we up to date no I
believe we have more moves let me get
let me just refresh my board so after
Knight E4 Rook E7 Knight D6 Bishop E6
and finally C D5 okay well pass pawns
must be pushed and all them that good
stuff Maurice is this tactically okay
tactically just fine for white looking
like white is starting to dominate that
position in the other game a big
development as well look at this
defensive move looking to guard his Pawn
the move Knight to B1 I was looking for
a knight move and I didn't think of
Knight B1 like seriously you're going to
put your knight back here and instantly
she pounced with the move Bishop to A4
that's a good-look move pinning the
Knight to the rook and attacking it of
course directly and he has responded
with Knight to D2 what a weird
reconstruction of the the pieces this
doesn't look like a construct I've ever
seen I've never seen white do this in
order to defend the position the the two
knights how did how did it even happen
the way the maneuver went about and now
the engines are saying this is great for
black and a very simple move you can
anticipate now is the to move B5 taking
the pawn out of Danger on that B6 square
and after a simple trade on B5 a takes
B5 and now per this this can always be
traded off at will the control of the C4
Square blacks now starting to think
about D5 at the right moment it looks as
though white has misplayed the position
in the last two moves and how you find
and she has played B5 by the way B5 is
on the board this is the position in the
game Advantage black as she has turned
the game around with this very nice
maneuver with Bishop D7 that prompted
that mistake on the other board just
quickly Nakamura has now played a move
that the engines did not like at all
after C5 the engines are saying big
position King f8 and that King A3 was
the the money move in this position King
A3 what a move marching the king up the
board making the king into a fighting
piece that's the maneuver the engines
wanted but Bishop F1 instead after King
FH Bishop F1 was played and now the
engines are saying Rook C7 creates
problems maybe dead equality you attack
this and after Rook C1 F5 tying down
White's pieces but I'm trying to figure
out why this move is not a big move now
than A5 it's suggesting and if now King
A4 some trickery with Knight A2 yes it's
starting to get a little bit weird here
uh these kinds of moves but it looks as
if white is not able to control
everything let's continue this line C2
well Knight B4 again and oh you can't
hold the C Pawn Yeah a bit of trouble
tricky computer esque defenses here now
it seems as though and King A3 did
happen that was my first guess although
the engine doesn't say it's the best
move but that was my first guess human
like move and it looks like Fabiano is
defending like a computer right now that
last move A5 and now he's saying make a
move engine saying dead equal game has
definitely turned around
and is it going to matter as it look at
at the clock Nakamura with 9 minutes on
the clock and change while Fab's down to
only four minutes and a couple of
seconds that's probably the most
dominant factor in the position now that
it's reached Dynamic equality and man
look at Naka he's sitting back sipping
tea got the hand on the hip you would
think he's he's uh watching some TV or
something California cool it's funny how
Nakamura um shifts from Red Bull to T
but yeah that line that Maurice was
showing that's pretty cool I mean you
see perpetuals with a rook you see
perpetuals with a queen but um seeing a
Perpetual with a knight that's a lot
less typical yeah and hitting the Rook
that that's tied to the C5 pawn and
clearly what nakam yeah and we just want
to go back just a quick second to this
position uh
after uh after the move C5 Just Want To
Boldly point out the obvious because at
first it wasn't obvious to me I thinking
well why didn't he go Rook here
attacking this Pawn on C5 if you dare
defend it with Rook C1 I've got this
lovely Fork Knight D3 check hitting King
on B2 Rook on C1 I for first it's kind
of rare to see this Knight you know
reaching into the position and going
Knight E8 checking the king hit and
picking up the Rook that was why uh
Fabby had to First preface the move Rook
C uh 7 with the move King f8 uh Bishop D
F1 covered the D3 Square just those very
tactics that I was looking at Rook C7
Rook C1 F5 King A3 A5 I believe were up
to date and and if we may jump if we may
jump to the other position really
quickly guys of this game has exploded
in Black's favor in a big way we'll get
back to the Nakamura game but C5 was
played C5 now you know in the maroxy the
point for the Hedgehog is to get the B5
D5 break you remove these pawns they no
no longer weaknesses and you're able to
get good play for your pieces well C5 is
a gift yeah we'll just give it to you
this break is not something that white
wants especially not under these
conditions Bishop C5 Bishop C5 and Rook
takes on C5 and suddenly all the black
pieces are fine the bind is gone this
pin is here always tradable on this
Square the inine really like Rook takes
but also the move she played was nice as
well KN back to D7 and black is for
Choice here White's Bishop is nothing
it's anemic now and black is still
looking at C4 squares chasing all of
White's Pieces away the trade did happen
Rook takes on C8 Rook takes on C8 look
at black what Vine happy lady this looks
very good and now it's up to White to
try to figure out how to maintain
equality as black is just perfectly fine
set up every which way it's not so bad
yet but this bishop on F1 might prove to
be the bad piece in this game we'll see
how this one transpires but there's
action happening on the other board as
well yeah that's right that's what
happens in the Hedgehog black seems
worse worse worse worse worse worse
worse and better yeah suddenly a single
trade of Pawns a favorable trade of
Pawns and then it's black is better and
that's one of the things that I always
liked about the Hedgehog is first of all
it's very awkward for white to decide
where he wants to win the game on the
king side on the queen side in the
center and often times when you dilly
dally about uh it's black who uh opens
up the position
advantageously uh when we went
a while ago I wanted to say I really
like white structure uh the position we
now have on the board after this Retreat
Knight C6 if you look at white structure
all of his pawns have four Pawn Islands
this Pawn on A5 still Yes it still
represents a potential weakness there
are ideas of of such as Bishop B5 King
A4 that that that still are there for
white but now that the pawn is on F4
it's even possible that Black's King uh
also has something that it can tickle
right got Knight on D6 moves we've got a
king F6 and yeah and I'm just thinking
that that that hiar is not happy about
the way he should not be happy I thought
he had a much cleaner Advantage uh
earlier 10 moves earlier where he really
looked like he was dominating and he's
given Fabby a chance to really defend
this position very well well I agree but
he he he probably missed that that move
uh night A2 right right that was
that's right that perpetual and still
being way ahead on the clock you got to
think that he's going to try to stir up
some tricks not that this bishay B5 King
A4 idea does look really enticing
because if we can get those two
protected past pawns we're going to
crash exctly we have to we have to note
though that our H3 Pawn is hanging at
the moment if if we move the bishop on
F1 so I think that Nakamura is going to
find uh a good time to do something like
that and really rattle Fabiana so this
game is is far from over oh without
question and Maurice but that one's
starting to look better for black better
in terms of what it used to be white was
just crushing in that position but take
a look at the other game this one's
getting very exciting it looks like she
missed an opportunity did Ha youan after
Queen D4 which looks like a great
centralizing move the engines were
screaming for Rook to C2 as a great move
the point is very nasty it's hidden if
you try to trade off this piece then all
of a sudden Bishop takes on B3 Knight
takes on B3 and then bam out of nowhere
a sacrifice on F3 the point being that a
I'm threatening Maiden one Queen takes
on H2 is mate and if you take it that
Rook showed up on the Square and queen
takes his mate anyway so Rook to C2 was
a serious boss move would have given a
very nice Edge because you couldn't
really bother this piece at all and this
the pin and all the tricks are still
maintained in the position instead of
doing that she didn't spot that idea she
decided to play Knight B6 aim for the C4
square and after Rook to C1 Rook to d8
no trades of Rook she wants to stay
active and then the move Queen to C3 was
played and now Queen D6 she's finding
all the best next moves now with this
maneuver and he has now played the move
Queen to C5 offering a trade of sorts
but as far as the in is concerned these
end games are better for black more
activity this Square will be
advantageous curiously the move Queen C5
is being suggested by the engine as the
best move hard move I think for a human
to play and she did not play it she did
not play she played Bishop takes B 3
instead uh in this position which has
given away some of her Advantage
according to the engine she should have
traded on C5 right away but the moment
you look at this even though it says
better for better for black
instinctively you say really is that
what I want to do very difficult move
that uh she did not find here allowing
takes and then dropping a knight into
the C4 Square was what the engine said
yeah but it's rapid chest and it's hard
to evaluate all that very quickly
instead she did take on B3 and after
Knight takes she has placed her night on
the C4 Square now hitting this Pawn only
a slight Edge for her now according to
the engines and the clocks are ticking
very fast she only has two minutes and
so does he this one is going to be a
nailbiter and we still had another game
to pay attention to On The Other Board
yes thank you Maurice that's right with
two minutes um only two minutes left for
Fabiano Carana in the his match between
Nakamura remember he needs to try to
even the score in the rapid CH of the
Rice's back will be against the wall
tomorrow and Blitz thees are saying that
Black's better by the way the engines
are giving black a clear Edge right now
in the position well look at how he's
coordinated his pieces finally which we
were boning for most of the game so he's
played this move Knight D4 and we were
trying to get the Knight onto D4 like
ages ago eons ago well I think actually
uh Hikaru uh missed a tactic in the
position he played the move Knight
D6 uh to C4 which I don't think was a
very good move and I think his intent of
course when he played Knight C4 was to
freeze the Knight and not to allow
Knight D4 I think his intent was to
capture on A5 and I think he just re
thought he probably stop right here and
he said okay well I'm you know I've got
it but then he realized well after
Knight B3 this uh SE pwn pardon me
pardon me catch up the ca pwn isn't as
dangerous
as he may have intended because this
king is just in time to make a very easy
blockade oh God that's so annoying it is
you because sometimes when you analyze
that you might think oh and White's
doing well and then you just kind get to
the position and and that for that
reason he Dro back with his knight uh to
D2 in order to protect the pawn on C5
and what a world of difference this
Knight on D2 had been sitting on that
gorgeous D6 square and is now that is
why the computer is Con considering
black is doing very well and black is
doing well in the other game as well
excuse me Jen black is doing well
because n did something bizarre he
traded first that's okay and after Rook
takes D6 he decided to play funky chess
A4 figuring he's going to undermine this
Knight on C4 now the only thing is this
looking at it it might be worse for
black but it might only I mean for white
but it might only lead to equality let's
see this line takes but what is he
planning after takes maybe Knight to C5
in this position expecting that he'll
win this Pawn back and also the pawn on
A6 is hanging however the engines are
giving the computer esque night B2 in
this position Knights don't normally end
up on squares like this one but the idea
being to be able to push this Pawn down
make a a threat with this Pawn very fast
and also drop a rook down to trade off
The Rook which looks like the best piece
to slow down the the pawn from Galloping
down the board she is sitting on this
position now with A4 on the board A4 for
and the issue is that both of them now
at 127 and this is indeed the
continuation she did capture and after
night to C5 she did find Knight to B2
this is game position as we speak with 1
minute and 15 seconds for Nei 1 minute
37 for how you find an exciting game
here and On The Other Board it's also
exciting somehow Nakamura has gotten
this position but still the engines like
black looks like black is doing quite
well in this position absolutely that's
right we've gotten a lot of updates here
and so it looks like Hera has snapped
upon Pawn snaggle upon Pawn exactly uh
we left
it excuse me we left it at Knight D2 and
Bishop dropped back to D7 first of all
opening up the square on E6 for the
night that was the key and that's going
to make a double attack on those two
pawns exactly Knight E4 we talked about
the four Pawn islands for white uh
Hikaru three but I know what you're
saying you can't really play before
exactly 6 Rook e won offering the pawn
Fabby said I'll take it Knight takes H4
Knight E6 and the game has turned
dramatically as Fabiano uh picked up a
pawn from a really bad position great
fighting fighting back there uh Bishop
C4 H6 and we're up to date and no we're
not we've got one more so now what
happened after H6 H5 looks like H5 has
been played all right H
offering but let's just take it exactly
which
what Bobby did and now nakur followed it
up with Knight to G3 well hold on we've
got a a B4 has I think been played some
yeah sorry we've got a we got let me
update okay so we're going to go back so
we got here uh Bishop C4 H6 B4 yeah
takes takes I'm sure Fabiano was really
delighted by that trade because that
pawn on A5 had been kind of sticking out
there Rook A7 activating H5 a second
Pawn Knight G3 and are we up the date
now Jen or we have a few more moves we'
got a couple more moves what happened
after Knight G3 what did after Knight G3
H4 was played and now Knight H Knight F5
check King F6 Knight H4 now if well
Knight H4 it's happened that has
happened yes okay okay so now we have it
on you play Rook A4 check oh Rook A4
check or Rook B7 check I was just
looking at the fact that your your your
minor pieces there are all lined up and
C5 is also hanging well indeed and I
want to take it yeah so I didn't know if
I should take it with Rook A4 check or
Rook B7 check I'm not sure uh okay but
let's go with your first ins synct Rook
A4 check King back to C3 what else
Knight takes C5 but now I have back a
Pawn on F7 aren't you with Rook F1 check
and then the question is yes Rook F1
check am I gaining the pawn back there's
this yes I am gaining the pawn back
because do you want to explain yeah well
after King G5 I've got knight3 check you
were thinking that we can't play Rook
takes F7 because then the Bishops defend
it but Knight F3 check and uh black will
lose this Pawn on F I'm wondering
because of King G6 there's no that
position is looking more and more dsh
but we should point out that the other
position is looking more and more wiish
or we should say winning maybe miss
something in there yeah there's there's
some tactics there but let's let's jump
to the other game as we see this
maneuver night B2 Rook A1 was played in
A3 a pawn you cannot touch because of
Rook D1 with some tactics to bring you a
knight to C4 and then to D2 and instead
Bishop takes A6 and now A2 on the board
Pawn all the way down to the A2 square
and danger because of Rook cheek coming
in and both of them down to only 30
seconds on the clock if I may update
this position right now we have this on
the board still the pawn on A2 Rooks
have been traded still the pawn on A2
but this Pawn is the thing if he if
somehow she can deflect this Knight and
get this Pawn going she's going to win
the game The King has now moved over to
F1 and again only 30 seconds on the
clock let's jump back to the other game
on the other game it's Fabiano who's
hurting on time he's got less than a
minute whereas Nakamura has five minutes
remember these guys have played a lot
more moves and there is a 10-second
increment that's why they have so much
more time than Nei and Yan and it looks
like uh Fabby is nursing a material
advantage but after Bishop
takes it's only whoa what was that
there's only one PA a Advantage this
looking very
dryish uh because of such reduced uh
material on the board unless we can
somehow get some tactics in with our
minor pieces Rook to F4 has just been
played so the uh note that the the
Knight on F3 is semi pin the problem is
if we attack it it can always just go
back to
D2 and uh then we wouldn't win any
material um instead Rook D1 check
happened after after Rook F4 and after
King E7 uh was Rook F4 a rook F4 check
Rook D1 check King E7 and now a quick
Bishop D5 Nakamura trying to to keep
that time in in The
Possession and in the other game by the
way guys just updated quickly after King
F1 how you find play Knight E3 check a
sterling move attacking this pawn and
after King E2 said no I don't want that
pawn I'm going to go after a piece on
this side and then King to D2 and she
said give me this one I want the B Pawn
instead now up a pawn in the position at
after Bishop to E2 and now Nei down to
only 4 seconds on the clock we should
see his clock time is ticking down
according to my clock he's he's down but
he's actually has 13 seconds left on the
clock King to D6 and she's up that a
pawn can she somehow make it work as the
white king is now very close to
curtailing it it looks as though he's
played now King to B2 trying to keep
that time on the clock moving quickly
but he's still down the pun at least for
now that's right so it looks like uh def
defensive skills in this game have been
pretty Sterling by both players as uh as
people are extricating themselves from
really ugly situations well I mean who
plays wh like that ex well it's really
uh it's been very surprising to my eyes
to see hikaro giving up what I thought
was just a very very big Advantage let's
get caught up with that game because he
got a lot of games and uh Kara trying to
do something with the only thing that he
has which is at SRA H Pawn exactly all
uh hikaro needs to do at this point of
course is to sacrifice his Knight for
the H Pawn Rook a knight versus Rook is
a quite an easier draw much easier than
Jer Kasparov think so Judith pogar
doesn't that's correct there was a
famous game between Kasparov and pogar
in which I guess it was it was time
pressure situation that caused her to
lose it though that's right but here
there's time pressure as well exactly
will give it a go that one's looking
more and more Dro though Nakamura should
be able to hold it barring some kind of
disaster look at him leaning back in his
chair but the other one is definitely
not dsh as she has made tremendous
progress as ha youan in this position we
were around this yes King C3 up and the
King went to B2 and she played G5
finally starting to look at the other
side of the Border a weakness on this
side distracting the king let's attack
on the other side and after G3 Knight E5
exploiting this small change in the
position and they are blitzing now we
should take a look at the board as it
looks as though she's making tremendous
progress she's just played Knight to C1
attacking the bishop and the Knight it
looks like the game is over she just won
a piece he no actually she did not my
apologies because he was able to take on
B4 but still it looks like it should be
nothing of an advantage for black in
some way this should be completely
winning yeah very easy Knight to D4 now
nibbling on the other side of the board
you can have my a pawn but I'm going to
decimate the king side he's just played
F4 that's not going to to help at all
his other pieces are on the wrong half
the wrong side of the board and she's
just going to start there it goes Knight
to E2 attacking the F Pawn and no way he
holds up in this position just pushing
trying to hold on to his pawns but now
the black king will be the thing in a
second as it will find the E5 square and
simple dominance on the other side an
easy win now for hauan keeping that
streak from yesterday three wins time to
win another one wow and Nei looked shaky
there he was shaken by that move Knight
C1 um well that's I want to review KN C1
but let's uh first take a second and see
if there's anything going on in Nakamura
well we do have that end game Rook and
night verse Rook so this is going to go
a little longer than we might have
expected we see if carolana actually
tries to uh squeeze this for a bit um
remember he does get 10 seconds for
every move he plays meanwhile let's go
back to that ephon game and see that
critical moment now we've got um now we
wait what happened wait a second how did
that pawn go to E5 instead of the king
she played Pawn E5 that was an inferior
move although she still totally winning
uh you have to rush forward this Knight
C1 move was fantastic yes I want to see
that Knight C1 move this was the moment
where Knight came to D3 check King to C3
and this was the moment of Knight C1
threatening both Knight takes B3 so that
this Pawn can promote as well as the
bishop and that's how we got the
position that we have he didn't and he
didn't have to play that King C3 move
did he before yes so after after
probably he was uh well advised to drop
that won with the King this King C3 set
up that beautiful tactic right because
because Knight C2 is not meting remember
the pawn on A2 will then be taken so um
wow just a great resourcefulness by Yan
though uh yeah I I really was hungry for
that King to come
chomping but still winning right you you
didn't like the movie E5 you thought she
should play King E5 well it looked like
it looked like uh the king would just be
dominant if it it would have been King
E5 was crushing King E5 was absolute
finished it would have all those pawns
would have disappeared the king would
have showed up on H2 just everything
would have been done in this position
the engines are saying easy win for
black in this position giving it a
seven-point edge even as it pass pawns
everywhere and we know in endings night
endings a really King and pawn endings
and that looks like a bad King and pawn
ending still the position is worse it is
losing for black out for white at the
moment white has managed to get all the
way down here but now a trapped looking
knight on this side of the board and
Knight better get out of there quickly
Knight G4 can be anticipated but then F5
and two pass pawns this Pawn doesn't
matter at all there is there's maybe
some trickery still but she has enough
time on the clock I think to make this
happen and he did not play the night
back instead he took the pawn and
allowed F5 to happen he took here
allowed F5 to happen on the board and
now King to B2 his Knight is slightly
trapped here looks like it's not going
anywhere at all I I think he's going to
lose easily now why did he leave his
Knight on this square and engines are up
saying 46 point lead that's oh might as
well call it mate because this Knight is
not going anywhere and she's played King
F6 he played King to C2 and now all you
need yes there she goes Knight to D6
she's slowly eyeballing this piece and
he's feeling it this Knight is going to
go down very quickly the Knight is now
guarded the F Pawn next move is King G7
King G7 will win the game cuz this KN
will be trapped and that's it this move
we don't even need to look at this game
anymore how you find is going to win
with ease King F King to G7 to threat
trapping this Knight on H6 and that'll
be all she wrote I'm surprised he left
it sitting on that square the only game
of Interest now will be this one and
what's going to be of interest is how
many more moves will we have to watch as
increment after increment after
increment plays a role here as of course
Karana is going to to make Nakamura
suffer for a little bit not because he
thinks he's going to win the game he
might maybe in some crazy Planet but
because it's always nice to annoy your
opponent for the next game make sure he
feels a little bit of annoyance because
he's the one under pressure there's no
pressure at all on his side to lose the
game and this one did end of course in a
win for black amazing play great game by
haifan that's right haifan just really
dominating uh this match now and uh
lucky luckily for Nagi um there's so
many games to be played tomorrow that we
can never count him out well yeah right
but the par is shaking a little I saw
him sh like yesterday he his confidence
was has really bad well when you lose
three games in a row it feels like the
rules of physics have been turned upside
down you the pieces don't move the way
you you've come to expect them in the
game between Fabiano and hikaro I would
definitely play uh Fabiano's position
obviously he's a piece up but it's a
it's a question of feeling confident
right I mean you just it's nice to have
a position that you're constantly better
constantly get better constantly it's a
confidence Builder is what it is and so
playing uh playing to the 50 moves not
necessarily entire 50 moves is a good
idea torture your opponent make yourself
feel good too let's see think about what
would Nakamura do if you wonder what
youed to do he would he would say
absolutely right play play play on and
essentially what Black's only winning
hope is is he wants to pin the King on
the border of the board any either on
the first rank on the last rank or on
the sides so that he can set up uh
checkmating threats if he's unable to
achieve that then essentially the game
he'll have no threats of winning and the
game will be a draw as we can see uh
what happened in the game was that he
CaRu quickly brought his King so that
it's not uh pinned to the side but now
it's on the second Rank and uh again uh
very very difficult impossible in fact
to make progress It's a theoretical draw
but still play on move 115 is the move
number move 115 65 is when The Rook take
Rook took on G5 the white Rook played
Rook takes G5 the last capture so now we
are waiting for the 50 move rule to be
in effect that will be if my math is
correct it's not it's not always correct
but my math is correct it'll be a move
115 when nak Moran say okay that's it
and actually it'll be a lot sooner
because Fabiano decided enough is enough
and they have drawn the first game you
try to win with Knight come on can't do
no can't
do not even if you went if you went on
time there's no mating material right oh
yes exactly I was just kidding although
I do like the that expression the night
of Shame so uh the night of Shame I
thought Mar said that the night of shame
I did not say that share the story okay
can't recall great first uh oh gosh it's
going to get better an impressive
Hedgehog play by Hui hon to take a
two-point lead and uh hikaro still has a
one-point lead but he'll be defending
the black pieces in our next game yes
anything can happen here in Rapid Chess
at The Showdown in St Louis this game
could have gone either way and it ended
up in the Third Way a draw and we've got
three more games by these two formidable
opponents um we saw right now how good
kowana can be at fighting back in the
other game yon Nei Nei still struggling
Yan now on a four game decisive streak I
mean there was a draw in between but all
the decisive four games that have been
held she won exactly so um his saving
race of course was at a first match at
as chass where he won two beautiful
games that's right can he find that
style remember you talk about mental
game and resilience um Negi one of the
youngest Grandmasters ever he's got to
have it in him too and you know what
Now's the Time to bring it up exactly so
we are going to take a quick break and
we'll be back with more from The
Showdown in St
[Music]
Louis the the first time that I think I
played Fabiano was at the New York was a
New York City and I believe 2003 we
played in a game 30 at the Marshal chust
Club he was uh a couple years older than
me he was already an established player
and I was sort of up and coming at that
time I was already a Grandmaster and
Fabiana was only about 22 2300 so I was
quite a bit better then um obviously he
was quite a bit younger as well so he he
progressed quite a bit I think we both
have a couple years ago we we both sort
of rose to the top of uh of the Chess
World and started playing each other in
um in top events so against Fabiano I've
done quite well actually I think I have
five wins if I'm not mistaken and one
loss it's it's four or five wins at any
rate yeah my record against Karu isn't
very good um I think in classical chess
I have minus three or so in Blitz uh my
record against him is also not good
things can change very quickly there are
some players who I had very bad records
against in the past and i' I've won a
couple games in a row and it's it's just
all all in the Dynamics and things can
change very quickly so even though I a
very good record um obviously one one
game can change everything and swing the
momentum so it's just very important to
keep on trying to play well and and uh
if I do I I think I can keep on you know
keep scoring very well against Fabiano
well you know Karu is uh is a very
interesting player because he he likes
to play lots of different types of
positions uh he likes to experiment and
he's always up for a fight uh I think my
biggest challenge against Fabiano will
be in the rapid I think it's where we're
most most evenly balanced I think I'm a
I'm probably a big favorite in Blitz and
a very slight favorite in bass chess and
Fisher random okay I I assume that hear
is considered a a clear favorite in the
blitz but I still think I have decent
chances and in the rapid I also think I
have pretty good chances um but it
really comes down to how how we're
feeling how our form is so I think rapid
chest is probably where we're most even
and it's probably where the games are
going to be the hardest fot too I think
exhibition match are always a bit more
relaxing for starters um it's not that
you don't prepare as much but it makes
it a little bit less stressful and I
think when that happens it's easier to
to play more interesting chess and more
creative chess we're playing um all
kinds of different forms of Chess um
different time controls faset chess is
still a rarity in um in tournament games
I think from spectator standpoint it's
much better uh to have interesting games
and and that's probably the biggest
advantage of exhibition matches as
opposed to just simply playing classical
chess all the time um but yeah he's he's
a really strong player and it's um and
one of the best in the world and it's
very interesting to play against him
it's it's only in the last couple years
that I would say it's become more like a
rivalry because we we've both uh reached
the upper echelons and we've both uh
been in the top five in the world for
some time
now
[Music]
for
day two of The Showdown in St Louis saw
the players play Fisher random and it
was caruana who drew first blood winning
the first game of the match but the last
laugh went to Hikaru Nakamura after he
won the next two games and now takes a
one-point lead in the match coming into
today but the next matchup was even more
fiery GM how you fun after losing two
games yesterday against Nei stormed back
winning three in a row dominating the
match and now she has the lead going
into day three coming up next here The
Showdown in St
[Music]
Louis
hello and welcome back to the showdown
in St Louis we've got round two of the
rapid and as we saw for the first game
of the rapid every round in Rapid proves
to be Topsy turby with the results
changing even among such world class
players like black Mora and kirana
Nakamura had an edge kirana had an edge
and ended up in a draw yeah but it
wasn't just an edge for Karo he had a
huge Advantage I thought very close to
winning in fact and he spoiled it and he
ended up having to defend uh rook and
Knight versus Rook so confidence boo
booster uh I would say for Fabby uh
because uh hikaro said it well he said
of all of the different
uh uh uh chess variant they of playing
that this was the one that was the most
difficult the rapid chess for Hikaru you
felt he had a big advantage in the other
disciplines and we'll see how he does uh
with the black pieces in round game two
and this is a Time control you guys it's
game 15 with a 10-second increment so I
like to call it rapid rapid and just
because rapid can be as long as game 25
with 10 yeah exactly and meanwhile the
blitz chess is going to be super quick
we've got a game three with a 2C
increment so that's going to go at the
speed of Maurice
talking which is pretty difficult you
that's right that's pretty fast and
we've got Nakamura and carolana smiling
and laughing that's nice to see it's so
important because these two guys of
course are are number one and number two
on the Olympic team although Wesley so
you know not that far behind right and
uh well as I asked Fabby he says well
well who's number one on our who's the
tournament who's going to be our Olympic
leader well that's what we're finding
out in the showdown in St Louis and the
clocks have been started clocks have
have started that's right and we've got
a sicilian oh oh rosalo okay so we saw
this in another game uh Rosal Lio Knight
F3 Knight C6 Bishop B5 Fabiana is
ducking the discussion of an open
Sicilian with D4 in the first move he's
played Bishop B5 and U let me get and we
have got another Sicilian in the other
game so Sicilian lovers this is your
round well it's strange uh my board
isn't updating at the moment so I do
apologize for that other game
is be between yon and no no not yet
maybe it will go in that direction
between Yan and Nei um so far I've got
it just just so far just E4 C5 Knight
of3 D6 so this could steer into a night
or after D4 but for some reason Yan is
taking this moment to think perhaps and
she has played D4 by the way going into
a night or but going back to our uh game
uh between
Hikaru we have the Russel Lia Bishop B5
D6 takes takes and
E5 this I thought that this so familiar
with E5 in this exact position I've seen
this before but I thought it wasn't much
for white captures right away oh
captures right away Knight E5 F6 it
looks like karo's played with the idea
that if a if a knight takes C6 there's
Queen D5 but what about Queen H5 check
that's the question what about CLE has
to be analyzed at home my friends G6 box
only move night6 you would think you
would think on you would think on a
first glance that this is just uh
wonderful for for white because we've
just picked up an exchange and a PA but
uh hikaro has something in mind here or
maybe it was in a different position
that he had something in mind
um well he has played F6 so we do have
this position on white to play White
could play this move Queen H5 check
which everybody wants and he has played
it G6 only moved Knight takes G6 so is
there anything else here is the question
the answer is no because in fact this is
the position what is this King F7 here
or something I'm not sure I'm wondering
if or queen D D5 yeah well first of all
the Knight is hanging so Queen D5 does
protect the Knight it introduces a
counter threat of Queen takes G2 so will
Castle to protect G2 now the question is
can black trap White's Queen which is
definitely an enemy territory but at the
moment the queen is looking like it's
ready to return to H4 and Knight C3
sorry I don't see what about Bishop A6
can we please take Bishop A6 in
somewhere and then Castle queenside I
don't think so don't think it's going to
be enough you're going to in between
move me with with a knight C3 and guess
what even if you capture my Rook on F1
big big deal I'll bring my queen back
I'm already a pawn up uh what am I
missing uh I'm missing something here
Maurice and the computer engines are
about to tell me what it is uh the
engines are shaking their heads just
like you are because it doesn't look
like there's anything here it looks very
clear at the moment anyway that not is
simply down material that's it and
that's hard to believe in this position
so we're going to see the mystery get
solved somehow after Queen to D5 which
was played castles and now King to F7
and the engines are saying we're just up
a whole three points in exchange and is
it a pawn as well yes and your
weaknesses and what what just make a few
moves Night Out Pawn out bring the
bishop into the game this position is
cold cut winning as far as the engines
are concerned concern so this is bizarre
Nakamura must have looked at it though
F6 is not a move you make and allow
Queen H5 check truly truly mysterious
situation on the board right now if if
it's some deep analysis it's going to be
amazing pure and simple but he's playing
very quickly he has not gone below 15
minutes as yet he's at 1524 that means
that he has kept going fast getting the
increments getting the 10 seconds per
move and Kon has to be wondering what is
the big deal what is the big deal and
looks like Nakamura is trying to
remember his analysis I mean think about
it if he looks the way he's looking at
the board he's like I think it's
supposed to go like this now which means
he went into this line on purpose yes
for sure but he's but but it looks awful
I mean it just it really does just look
awful as you look at it it doesn't look
like he has any real compensation uh the
engines are are saying any move for
white is good and
maybe can you imagine the preparation
sitting at home looking at this line and
preparing it and saying yeah you know
what I think maybe we could give up an
exchange in a pond and it's going to be
just fine that is very this is bizarre
and amazing if it's tall sound this
would be just total human Ingenuity you
could never guess at this variation if
you had the white pieces you could never
guess that he would play this line well
he's played the move F5 introducing the
idea of Knight F6 into the game but the
problem with F5 is it also um opens up
the H3 Square as a retreating option for
the queen so because the bishop no
longer ex covers
H but I so Knight F6 if we could play
Knight F6 and remove the pawn on F6 from
the board make a special move where we
we get rid of X6 and play Knight F6
notice that the queen indeed would be
trapped then it would be trapped but
that is that is not the case here
so uh I mean Knight F6 and and queen H3
F4 is that a
threat no talk about threats is not is
not even the right word there are no
real threats here black the only if you
look at it clearly the queen can come
out the queen is going to be free so
just just objectively looking at this
board the Queen is safe the question is
what does white
have what does black have that says I
have full compensation for the fact that
I've just donated an exchange and a I'm
still looking at seven to six2 what did
you get I mean it just it's amazing
there is the only thing you can look at
and really point to is the light Square
Bishop right the he has a light Square
bishop and the other and and Nakamura
Nakamura is a light Bishop white does
not that's it aside from that it's you
can't say great Pawn formation your Pawn
formation sucks your king position is
better no your king position is worse
open files no no open files for the The
Rook nope what do you point to this this
is just this just looks bad I'm going to
go out on the limb and say it's bad for
black I think just go
scratch this is incredible that this has
happened I think he made a mistake going
into the line he mixed up lines and now
he's just in a lost position he mixed
this up with something similar probably
maybe something where there was a queen
trap with Knight F6 yes I think so I
think that's what happened he just just
like a a mistake we saw him do it in the
game yesterday where he played Queen D2
remember he said he played Queen D2
instead of Queen D3 uh in that game with
uh what was that what was the game was
it game one where he played Queen D2
instead of queen queen D3 Queen D2
instead of Queen D3 in the bask it was
in the bask that's right so all the way
back then and uh and he said if I had
just played Queen D3 it would have been
different now it looks like one of those
F6 Queen H5 one of the most incredible
mistakes you'll see on a chess board
from a player of this level and I think
he's just lost I think he's in big trou
and not and Fabby is not confused
anymore looking at this it's his
rightful play should win this game no
and he's actually just going for it here
moving his Knight into the attack and
this this roundabout way um cap
capitalizing on the uh the weak G5
Square so he's he's played a series of
moves that might look at first a little
strange but in fact it looks like
Nakamura is going to have some trouble
now dealing with Knight G5 and Bishop F4
both flooding into the position actually
he played the top move by the engine 92
was the engine's top move well he's
played 92 and he's routed his night over
to H3 where now these key G5 and F4
squares are now right for the taking and
D has played Knight G5
check forcing the king to drop back to
keep protection of the Knight and I
think at this point uh Fabiano is ready
to drop his Queen back so that in case
the Night comes out he'll have
opportunity to trade remember he not
just an exchange it's an an exchange in
a pond so this is just like
overwhelming uh from a material point of
view simply overwhelming for white and
after Rook to E1 bring the bishop to F4
and Bishop to E5 it's just one and car
is just looking he's just curled up his
lip and thear is just like ah what have
I done completely completely lost look
at how disgusted he is and that's a
clear indication he cannot believe it
this is just one of the worst games you
have ever seen in play and there goes
Bish actually even prettier because
Nakamura played E5 to prevent Bishop F4
and Knight E6 but Bishop F4 anyway
because uh if takes Knight E6 obviously
winning the house there with a the
bishop on G7 intake so that's a body
blow Fabiano I like how Fabiano is not
thinking that long he's just really
saying you think you're better than me a
blitz but not when you not when you let
me play Queen H5 CH well this ain't
Blitz like you said raid is where he's
going to have a chance uh this is not
Blitz but Bishop at four you can
virtually resign the engines are up at
fivepoint lead that's a full Rook for
those of us who know Rook equals five
points uh this is over well Bishop Rook
E5 and Bishop B5 are threats here
because you can't touch the the bishop
because of I mean I think I think that
that would be a threat no maybe not so
what want you wanted say that so you're
saying like for example after Rook B8
let's see how do we get this you you
were saying oh well Rook takes E5 Bishop
takes E5 you saw the mate but it's so
rare to have a bishop on E8 that it's
actually not a Checkmate on F7 there's
another threat guys coming possible
Queen takes G7 check right now is a
nasty threat Queen takes G7 so if Rook
to B8 Queen takes on G7 the engines are
pointing out that that would just Bishop
takes E5 and thank you very much and
byebye you don't need to play this one
again but it looks like he's instead
played Bishop F6 right to deal with the
threat and queen to B 7 ouch look at
that one now the threat of Knight H7
mate on the board and the Rook is
hanging in the corner time to stop call
it in throw in the towel this one's over
this one should be resigned right now
what a what is a miniature 20 moves
Queen B7 Nakamura should not make
another move now and he will be
disgusted with himself for this mistake
look at that face telling the entire
story night one of his worst games
you've ever seen him
not seen Nakamura allow this and it's
all from an opening mess up somehow he
just he just thought something was right
and instead he's he's continuing taking
the Knight that was threatening to play
Knight H7 mate and now ignoring that
Bishop takes takes C5 we can take
instead right we can just take Bishop
takes E5 that's what he did with a M
thread on G7 The Rook hanging on A8 no
counterplay at
all this is over it's just a question of
when you resign because it's over it's
not a it's not a fle to say this is the
worst game I've seen yeah I've never
seen wor any game I mean period you just
don't see you don't see him play like
this he would not play like this in
Blitz in bullet in bullet there it is
he's resigned gosh unbelievable the
matches even after unbelievable loss wow
I want to know what their reference is
for this queen allowing Queen H5 check
it must be some very similar opening
where it's allowable and like
uh some kind of twist there perhaps
maybe with a there's a lot of gambits
you like the sianos Gambit and the uh
ruy Lopez where you allow this queen H5
check but in this particular position
just turned out to be awful wrong
position for the move F7 F6 if hikaro
wanted to play Queen D5 which he
actually did later he could have started
right away with Queen D5 attacking the
Knight and if the Knight was forced to
drop back then play Bishop G before
we've got everything that looks like a
reasonable chess game Instead This
howler F6 a how move and then it's just
an exchange and then actually very nice
play because there is a chance that the
queen could get kicked around and bad
things might happen but Fabby just
played it really well this whole Knight
E2 he maneuvered his knight from C3 all
the way over to H3 and now suddenly the
queen was on the offense it wasn't just
simply a Target and just crushed Bishop
F4 is nice this was a very nice move by
the way if you saw this in a Simo yes I
mean this the kind honestly this is the
kind of stuff I see an assimo i the
they'll play F6 and I'll go oh you don't
know the queen H5 check oh I'm sorry and
then the game is over so clearly there
was a mixup Queen D5 looks like a
reasonable move but F6 he went into some
kind of analysis that was not the
analysis and caused this to happen to
himself one of the worst games he's ever
played in his life probably for the last
10 years he will say it himself and the
bad things we're saying now he'll say
even worse about himself because even
when we compliment him on good play he
says no no no I played a bad game I
don't know what what he's going to say
about this one but the good news is we
get to look at the other game in full
right now and that one is a barn burner
a lot of fun happening in that position
so let's jump right to it that's right
and I I want to shout out to some of our
our tw Twitter followers um Andrew isbel
says he car was just trying to look weak
against the bishop B5 Sicilian and will
bust out his real lines in the London
dress classic that's a very creative
Theory but Nakamura is a very
competitive person he's not losing them
to look weak exactly no way um but
thanks for shouting out the London chess
classic that is the final stop of the
grand chess tour and um we'll be
commenting on it absolutely so we do do
have the nidorf and the English
so-called English attack with Bishop E3
E6 G4 okay inviting a very complicated
game after the move E5 uh if you want
you can play a Carz attack as black with
the move H6 uh White now doesn't go for
the H4 G5 Alliance but rather he goes
Bishop G2 but uh after E5 there's now
this double attack uh against the pawn
on G4 as as well as the Knight on F on
D4 so the Knight jumps to F5 and you
think oh this looks really really good
for white until you see this move H5
undermining the protection of the Knight
on F5 if you do something pardon me let
me get that again if you do something
with the G4 Pawn black is ready to snap
on e4 and the Knight won't have
sufficient protection there we go G5
Knight takes E4 Knight takes G7 check
Bishop takes G D7 Knight takes
D5 okay Knight
G3 this is very Sicilian play right here
um in general when black it's such a big
Center in the Sicilian it's good news
but notice that White's activity is is
ample and that's just kind of like an
extreme version of the Sicilian in its
Essence that the Sicilian usually black
has a better Center but uh is behind in
development this is a a macro version of
that it feels like an accelerated
version of whatever you try to get into
Sicilian for either side exactly we've
got a really really sharp position on
their board and we do have to move E5 E4
so black is basically inviting white to
take this Pawn on H5 in return for this
Pawn on B2 I'm sure huifan will not give
up her B2 pawn and she defended it with
a move c h is probably a goner anyhow
right and she did take it on the very
next move and the bishop now has a
square a good Central Square on E5 so
from White's point of view she's a happy
camper right she's a pawn up uh but on
the other hand a little bit disordinate
piece over here on H5 and it comes down
to that alltime opening question
favorite opening question where are you
going to put your king as white right I
mean we can very very easily visualize
that Black's intention is just to
develop his bishop and going long it's
not going to be so easy for white uh
White's going to enjoy her extra Pawn
but has to deal with her her King
position F4 well she came up with this
concept of f4 to deal with your your
issues question of where you're going to
put your king cuz that forces on pant
right right because you can't move the
bishop away because then the Knight gets
to Nestle in into that gorgeous Square
exactly so the play has been very very
forced up to this moment takes on
passant Queen takes F3 which gets that's
one move closer to Castle and queen side
and also introducing our Rook into the
action um so this is just simply looking
very good at the moment for white unless
Black's counterplay gets there quickly
ooh castles castles taking advantage of
the pin in the in the situation so now
we got to ask ask ourselves can that
queen move anywhere nice and then um
reinsert the uh the threat like
something like Queen A5 I would I would
I would look at just because it it is
hitting
A2
but is that enough if you just maybe I
play Bishop C4 to defend A2 but also to
attack now if I take on E3 you just have
checkmate with Queen takes F7 that's
right so that's inadvisable is that our
Scholars made fight Scholars mating pH I
mean I'm sure you taught that a lot in
your career that's right yeah F2 and F
him and watch out I was about to say I
instead of Queen A5 I thought Queen C7
but I'm really doubting uh Black's
position because even if you do win this
piece oo you're going to face a world of
hurt I mean even even something as uh
brutal as Bishop C4 takes a bishop even
something as brutal as this with that
King still stuck in the center uh
there's going to be ample compensation
and this is a position for you and
Maurice you love these open Sicilians
sacrifices Galore I'm saying I'm just
saying I think White's looking real good
I don't know if this is uh Theory or not
but first impression is Black's in
trouble I think you uh show something
very instructive though with you remove
Bishop C4 which just looked crushing
because Nei um played Bishop to E6 to
make sure that that didn't occur because
honestly um that pawn I think would just
be too difficult to to um to defend
after that move in all those lines
I was played and that that's got to be a
good move um and then because because it
also is an attacking and a defensive
move right and addition to stopping your
Bishop C4 um we're also hitting A2 which
is to come in in handy and we're running
Bishop D5
okay so it's a super multi-purpose
move I got I got to throw it over to
Maurice are we in theory Maurice I know
that this is a real sharp line and it's
been played before but I haven't seen
this particular position well I haven't
had time to even research the position
quite honestly because I've been looking
at all these crazy variations that have
stemmed from it the engines did not like
to move E4 in the opening they thought
D4 was better but right now there's a
critical moment you see the chaos
erupting on the board it's clearly just
wild here believe it or not the correct
move as far as the engines are concerned
was
G6 out of nowhere this move
G6 offering this Pawn on G6 and now
Bishop to D3 amping up the tension in
the position not giving black a chance
to just play fluidly in the game of
course Bishop G6 check is huge here and
you can't touch the bishop because of
the mating problem on this line simple
moves like Bishop to to F7 for example
White's ready to take on D4 now you
talked about the opening of the eile Y
looks like that's happening there crazy
chess it's not completely over but it's
certainly Advantage for white instead of
that she played the move Knight to F6
check and how many players would in just
half a second kill that Knight on F6
just Bishop takes right away that was a
possibility but he's he sat and thought
for some time and played the engine's
first move King to
f8 now you see a move like that I mean
to me that's just like putting red meat
in front of a dog it's just are you
kidding me the engines are saying
z0 Z as in triple Zero's perfect
equality you're right come take your
equality and I'll show you something but
this position it's saying nothing at all
for white all chances Bishop D2 H4 in
fact the first two moves H4 and Bishop
D2 on the engine's list if you play
Bishop d before your worse crazy crazy
chess has broken out here wow and it's
gotten even crazier look at these last
two moves that have been made it looks
like after King f8 what after King f8 we
have uh takes on D4 and then Nei has
ignored the threat to his bishop and
just played Rook to C8 wow with the idea
that if uh we take that Bishop off um we
can we're going to now make a discovery
um well and
you're well I was I was also thinking uh
you could just try to take the Queen but
yeah it was going for
me sorry Jen you wanted to say Knight to
D4 check was actually Knight E5 is
best this is winning now Rook C takes D4
was a blunder C takes on D4 was a
blunder by how you find this position is
now winning for black according to the
engines so why so let's let's try to
figure out why so now what if we just
try to play um shuttle our King over to
B1 and well remember what we were saying
earlier but it's all about the King
position and uh yeah no it's not happy
I'm just wondering uh do you find sh
Sanctuary over here that is a good
question so this is the opposite the
opposite version of the Greek gift
usually we see it over on the other side
of the board with the bishop takes H7
Jack that's over but the problem is
we've got no Defenders on the queen side
none right we need to stick a knight on
C3 the knight's on F6 even then we might
be losing cuz you just play Rook Tak C3
right so yeah so I'm thinking if you go
to King B1 you may suffer there Bishop
takes A2 not may suffer will sufferer A2
is crushing the game is she's lost she
took on D4 was a horrible mistake now
she's lost Rook to see it all of Black's
pieces are attack blacks the one
attacking look at that can you believe
it second ago we were thinking about the
the black king being the more insecure
piece on the board and like I said there
were a couple of moves for white Bishop
F4 was one Bishop D2 was one everything
else the engine thought was worse for
black this move King f8 is simply
spectacular quiet king move I'm I'm
right in the middle of of gunfire it
looks like but no problem the F7 Pawn is
enough and in one move she tried to play
calmly and didn't realize Rook C8 was
coming and now that's it there are no
sufficient ideas in fact the only move
being given is to take on E5 allow this
position to happen Knight takes and then
any move even Bishop C4 is being thrown
in there as a move Bishop C4 actually
being considered the best move at least
you're on the queen for the moment
unfortunately after Knight takes Rook
takes Rook takes this position is up in
exchange is it a clear exchange uh one
Pawn maybe this is her best line maybe
this is her best line to try to go for
this and hope to survive what a sterling
play by um Nei in this game I mean both
of these players are really putting him
on shell I think Inc King B1 she played
King B1 that's going to be painful he
just has to find Bishop A2 now and he's
got three times as much time as her as
well plenty of time I mean he's
certainly going to see Bishop takes A2
so I mean have seen they seen it already
for sure yeah but so I mean the only
reason he wouldn't played is if he
misses something in a variation so I
think that we're going to see two really
crushing victories I mean uh yeah
they're really taking the measure of one
another aren't they and they're
dominating uh each other various games I
don't know exactly why that is I mean
that's take a closer look at Bishop T A
too for those those out there you know
this is one of the most important
tactics in chess normally we see it on
the other side of the board analyzing um
what happens on uh Bishop takes A2 check
King takes A2 we were looking at Knight
B4 I think I threw in Queen A5 check
first I'm not 100% Reon for that was
probably that well after night B4 check
I was a little bit concerned about a
move like King B3 and it wasn't as clean
in my view and I thought that okay what
you do is you go Queen A5 check if you
go King B3 now well I've got the same
I'll I'll get the same setup as I want
which is this Knight on B4 and this
queen coming to A2 so whether the
Queen's on A5 coming to A2 or on A4
coming to A2 doesn't matter there's
simply no defense here too bad I can't
put something on C4 right right well you
can you can toss in what we call a spike
check or two but that's it does there's
nothing else you can do I'm not going to
take that night so we're just one move
too late by way that's the problem but
that but you know that's a sicilian for
you so we think we think this bishop
takes A2 is you know lightning and
thunder end of story Bishop takes A2
yeah it's the end of the world I mean if
I if I try to play King A1 you can just
still play Queen A5 right and now I've
got that same anchor mechanism of
protecting the A2 Square so that my
queen is a about to give a Checkmate on
the A2 Square Bishop
D2 Bishop
D2 very good no no no I think I just
have Queen A4 though because oh you have
Queen A3 check that's very important I
mean and then at least I am kicking yeah
so let's let's look for hold on so
you're saying Bishop A2 King A1 okay
well maybe I should just play Knight
B4 Bishop B3 Bishop B3 looks that very
good thank you Maurice that clears the
cobwebs completely right because now
we've got Queen A5 check and mate on A2
so Bishop B3 simple by the way take a
look at this line in this position after
King takes A2 Queen A5 King B1 I was
wondering about your move yeah Knight B4
check this move Knight D7 and I said
well what if I plug the hole right now
you can't make me as easily until the
engine said wake up smell the coffee now
the Bishop gets in on the party as well
so Pawn takes and now Queen check King
over and a nice little tidy Checkmate so
no way to stop what's coming Bishop
takes a and he has played it Bishop
takes A2 check is now on the board black
is completely winning in all lines this
game is for all intents and purposes
over maybe somehow he'll slip but I
don't think so and I think that both
players Nakamura and haifan will
remember this second game in in a way
that's disgust only that'll be the
emotion it'll be disgust I the the it's
falling for Queen H5 that's a beginner's
tactic you you teach your your students
and falling for Bishop H takes A2
another one it's just like are you
joking this happened to me these are
world class Grand Masters and she's not
betraying any emotion she's not Nakamura
esque in showing the disgust on her face
but no doubt she's feeling the embarrass
harassment inside of playing this kind
of position and getting hit with Bishop
takes A2 she played King to A1 and now
he just has to find Bishop to B3 among
other moves but Bishop B3 is the most
decisive in this position Bishop takes
uh Bishop takes up a great position on
B3 and then everything else is just is
just money that's right but I I think
that the the key there was missing Rook
C8 um one the reason she played King B1
is cu she only had three minutes in her
clock and she probably didn't didn't
really uh see the idea sacrificing the
queen right you know it's like it at
that point it just like things looked
really ugly and she needed more time to
save herself but R8 I think was like
really the moment at which things turned
around well think of the emotional tosy
Turvy uh that huan has been feeling in
this game no doubts when she played the
move F4 she liked her position
she foresaw aasan captures Queen takes
D4 she foresaw this position and thought
hey this is really really good for me
look at this you know I'm a pawn up I've
got my knight coming to F6 I've pinned
the pawn on D4 Bishop E6 she probably
said to herself that's the only move she
was looking at Bishop C4 and how sweet
it is after Bishop E6 she's probably at
this exact moment her mindset was
probably I'm winning but hey let's get
an update from the game because he did
not play Bishop B3 he played Knight to
B4 so let's see if that gives a if that
gives her any opportunities here
night B4 I I suspect that this is
winning as well no it's not no it's not
horrible mistake horrible mistake on on
his oh oh sorry my bad the engines have
changed their minds as well Queen B7
looked like it had changed things no it
is in fact still there but it's much
less than before Bishop B3 was a killer
but Knight B4 is a move and she has
played the best response Bishop to D2
trying to create some trickery on the
board but he is
she has definitely you know caused some
little bit of drama he has now to find
the move Queen takes D4 oh sweet he has
to play carefully now he has to play
care he has play more brilliantly than
before Bishop B3 was easy but now he has
to play with a little bit of caution and
find the Right Moves first slip night
before before not a bad move it turns
out I misspoke the engines were not
calculating deeply enough yet but at the
moment she's finding ideas she's finding
ideas to defend let's look at some
pretty checkmates after Queen D4 though
I want to see the position after Knight
B4 Bishop D2 Knight Knight B4 confusing
move not the best Bishop D2 best move
for white setting up check uh captures
and being able to bring the queen over
now we're looking at Queen takes D4 by
the way according to the engines Queen
D4 is the only move there's no more move
anything else loses for black that's
where he is anything else actually loses
the game so black must find Queen D4
right now or lose the game go down a
full piece that's what the calculations
are at the moment so if Bishop C3 now we
get to to play this uh this pretty idea
yes we learned these checkmating
patterns in uh our
Basics uh Checkmate and then and then if
instead let's take a look at some other
lines there so after Bishop
C3 if you take on D4 now we we get to
checkmate with the rock so the old back
rang
checkmate so Queen takes D4 Bishop C so
instead of Bishop C3 maybe just Bishop
takes B4 or something well we can go
over uh don't grab your knight and think
that you can go Knight C2 check because
of course the Knight is pinned so I'm
thinking Queen A3 may be uh White's uh
best
chance in this position and now if we
play Rook
C2 well I'm going to take on B4 with a
check yeah that's true okay I'm not
going to yeah it's okay let's try again
never mind
um so he Nei has made his task much more
difficult with uh the move Knight we
play R so if we play no we can't really
play Rook C I'm trying to play like
something like Rook C1 here but then
with the idea that if you take with the
Rook we have Queen takes D2 but you can
just take with the bishop you just said
it Jen you just said it you should have
don't even Queen takes D just switch
your move order Queen takes D2
right now and
byebye M beautiful finish that was the
one by the way look at this variation
yes I'm going to ask you to defend just
keep on your board just my God L than
two minutes for both players move the
instead of Queen A3 that's not the best
move Bishop takes B4 try Bishop takes B4
okay Queen takes B4 Queen takes and now
Knight D7 Knight D7
check King moves uh wherever you want to
go and then Knight takes
E5 and look at this position where's the
win actually it's still winning with
with Bishop to B3 but it you still your
king moves I think it's G8 or wherever
G8 is the right square and Knight takes
E5 Bishop to B3 and now you're still
winning because you have Queen A4 check
coming but it's totally different it is
totally different now a completely
different win and that's why he
struggling and it looks as though he
will blow this game I I I have a feeling
he's got to find Queen D4 and he's
probably not happy with what he's
calculating and it's the only move and
he has less than a minute on the clock
he found it and played quickly though
play quickly he has found the move and
now she has to find Bishop takes on B4
that's a key defensive move she only has
two minutes though this position is
crazy and she did not find it she played
Knight to D7 instead that one I did not
see coming or analyz this one is is
actually far worse and he's found King
G8 she missed a golden chance and now
all her moves lead to defeat she missed
sitting there all this time missed the
line where Bishop takes B4 her best
chance and now there are no simple moves
at all to play she has nothing easy to
play in this position not easy of course
Knight D7 check was a little a little
Cheapo that if Queen D7 there is Bishop
takes B4 check and that's why she was
playing for a trap that simply a she
missed a great chance and now there are
no moves there's not even a try actually
there's just there's nothing to do
there's nothing to do everything is
Queen A3 is now Knight C2 check picking
off the queen there are no more
tries uh pity pity for her yes he he did
find the right move and unfortunately
she did not find the stiffest defensive
idea and now she's she doesn't even have
a real move to try what could we do
there's just nothing the problem is is
that if she captures the bishop on E5
which is threatening to give mate on B2
the simple Knight C2 check check King
takes A2 that's a second piece sacrifice
Queen A4 check if you drop back with
your king that's a different check so
You' be compelled to play Queen A3 but
the body counts is is not in your favor
well and now besides you're going to get
mated anyway and now this Rook C2 yeah
just uh I mean this game was F fantastic
in terms of those of you watching at
home for tactics especially tactics
specific to the cilian it was almost
like every move there was a beautiful
series of tactical ideas giving up the
bishop on E3 you know just playing for
the initiative but I really like that
uh experienced Sicilian player would
have found that move G6 what um uh well
she's made a move she has made a move
she took on E5 so we're getting get the
line that we just looked at yeah and
we're expecting now Knight C2 check by
Nei he's got a minute on his clock so
he'll just double check his calculations
he found it it's very straightforward
King takes A2 Queen A4 check that's
resigns and now either resigns or queen
A3 that's no that's resigns that's got
one or the other she did play it wow
just giving away the
queen well it was better than Checkmate
and I guess it's better than uh it's
it's still make coming some kind of yeah
that's the problem this is not just a
uper Queen situation you hanging on D1
by the way just if you want to count you
have a handshake so a real Clash a very
very sharp yeah very very sharp game uh
very typical of Sicilians at first sight
I really thought oh my goodness Nei was
going to go down to defeat once more and
then he found some really fine moves and
huifan over overlooked uh the counter uh
attack
great he had to come back though he was
getting steamrolled I mean yes four out
of five games he lost four of them four
out of five
if he had lost another one he could just
grab the losers check now and go home
but with this win he has stem the
bleeding and now only at minus one in
the overall match uh so and he's got to
be feeling good about this game this
game showed culating play on his part
great move Rook C8 he did allow the
Knight B4 like mix up though that I have
to say was a little off but it's rapid
so anything could happen especially as
you call it J rapid rapid you're not
going to find all the super accurate
moves at all times and he still showed
his medal and found the move Queen takes
D4 and boy she missed the chance to make
it a little bit more difficult for him
and he just steam roll great match so
far that was just phenomenal if you take
the the tactics that were in just that
15-minute game and you could spin yeah
you could write a book about it right
you like chapters after chapters I love
it I love it so those of you thinking
about playing the Sicilian but you're
not sure you Analyze That Game by
yourself without a hand write down all
the Variations by the time you're done
with that you're ready to play you'll
have some feeling of uh the ideas and
strategies and tactics for both sides
let's take a look at the results after
those games so not Kon has managed to
even the score in his mini match against
Nakamura he's got one and a half versus
half in the rapid and he um got nicked
for the full point yesterday in fish
random but now he's
even and uh CaRu looks like a real
Oracle there he said the raap was going
to be his biggest test Who Wants to Be
an oracle of his own demise exactly
meanwhile Yan still a point ahead
against Nei but Nei has even out the
rapid and as you said you know he's
shown that GD and that resilience and
ability to pick back up after four
losses in a row to be F exactly and uh
we will be back with the the third round
of this rapid match and K you just kind
of have
toting getting more
thrilling
[Music]
I'm very glad that I could be invited to
play here actually I've been follow the
sing for c for for for many times and uh
of course uh this time I could make
myself come here it's a one for thing
I've never been here but I've like seen
so many pictures online and videos like
I I think like I know stuff here I have
to look at the king of course and the
Hall of Fame and yeah it should it
should be exciting to see like the chess
club outside of Facebook pictures yeah I
think the format of this exhibition is
unique cuz we are not playing like
classical standard games probably more
serious but probably lack of fun so what
we doing here include Basque and
official random it's all you know n
spectator is the more enjoyed I feel a
lot of um the games in classical ch um
the theory part it really um makes the
battle being the actual battle is often
fought at home or like it's not really
being seen by the audience and I think
we as players we are capable of creating
a lot a lot more interesting chest um if
we could just get away from all that
preparation so hopefully uh with a
format like this uh both of us um will
be able to bring uh our best creative
chest to the board and that should make
it exciting for everyone to watch as
well and for my opponent Nei we played
several times I think from very young
age I think I've played who the first
time and I was like 10 or something so
we've played a lot of games over the
years of we've been evenly matched but
she's just been getting stronger and
stronger for my expectation I just hope
that I could show some you know some
brilliant ideas just try to enjoy the
game um the last time I played a m I
played a match when I was like 14 or 15
with another um another strong women
Grandmaster Katarina Lano and I got beat
badly in that one so uh I look forward
to taking my revenge this
[Music]
time
oh you're WR hello and welcome back to
showdown in St Louis well luckily for
Nakamura the saying you're only as good
as your last game is just a cliche
because that would be a bad situation
for him truly his worst game in the last
10 years and we've got Nakamura in this
position also playing something very
similar to what he did in the first game
is white um he played B3 and move one um
just trying to kind of get out of theory
and well he started with Knight F3 in
this third game and then he combined it
with a queenside fianchetto kingside
fianchetto by Fabby and quickly he did a
kingside fianchetto so something similar
but uh I'm a little bit surprised by his
very very non- theoretical approach uh
in these rapid games yeah well I think
so in a way it makes some sense he feels
like the longer the game goes on the the
more likely it is to become a bullet
game where he has an ed
so that if he plays something kind of
more strategic that makes a game loss 60
moves maybe I mean so obviously so far
his strategy hasn't been working and
both of the games both of the rapid
games it's gone kind of poorly for him
right that's true yeah I mean he he
ended up struggling for the draw after
getting a great position in the first
one and then obviously the second one
was just a massive disaster right
opening disaster and he has just played
this move d4 so it's not going to be a
grunfeld defense so he's kind of trick
Fabiano in in a non-g Grom Feld uh way
but uh after the move E5 which is very
common in these situations D takes E5
Knight G4 taking advantage of this pin
along the diagonal uh black usually
comfortably recaptures this E5 pawn and
gets a pretty even game so E5 is
certainly one approach let me just see
what uh he did play E5 by the way but he
took a different way of recapturing the
pawn after takes he did not play my
suggested Knight G4 he played Knight on
F6 to D7 instead Bishop G2 and this is
the position on the board on the other
game we have another open
Sicilian and this time the players uh
have reversed seating seating
assignments uh we did see this Carz
attack with H6 H4 is the most
challenging move and now E5 by hoan and
again I I think we're going to see a
knight F5 variation I absolutely love
the spirit from you find you know after
getting crushed on the other side still
going for the principal in sharp lines I
can take you I can take you down in
these melees I think one key though is
that last game she she gave herself a
big disadvantage on the clock she was
way behind I didn't pay pay that much
attention because it seemed that well
Queen takes D4 by Nei in that game too
he was down to one minute that's true I
think just those last couple moves he
spent a lot of time but leading up to
that point he had a big Edge on the
clock I see I wasn't was like 3 to 9
Minutes at some point but then then I
think when he slipped a little bit with
that slightly inaccurate move knife
before he suddenly had to spend like
seven minutes to double check all the
variations with Queen D4 so that's how
it went down but you know what that's
exactly when he needed the seven minutes
that's the key and if if Yan had seven
minutes to in at that moment where she
didn't find her key resource and instead
played Knight D7 check uh that would
have done Tri for her so exactly time
management is so key in these rapid
games especially when you're playing a
Mainline Sicilian where there's bound to
be tactical Madness right I hear you Jen
but I also have to think to myself that
in that situation she had a lot of time
to think about this idea Queen takes D4
she while he was thinking when he when
he played Queen D4 it's not like it
shocked her you you remember it's not
like she went oh my God Queen D4 I
didn't even see that move when Queen D4
appeared on the board she instantly
played Knight D7 and I think that that
was her preparation she probably could
not find another move while she was
sitting there and decided to play this
idea to see if he would fall for he
played very quickly to see if he fell
for the tricks and of course he was not
going to take the Knight on D7 that was
completely ridiculous he just moved his
King away and that was the end of that
so I think uh for her as far as as far
as she's concerned she should have used
her time more wisely there but maybe she
saw Bishop takes B4 and thought it lost
anyway and didn't want to go down that
line now they're in this very super
sharp line let me just jump ahead to
that position they're in this sharp line
with the Knight on F5 and it's
surprising that she's stopping to think
here you know you walk into this kind of
sharp crazy chest you probably should be
a bit prepared and here she's stopping
to try to remember her analysis as the
Knight has landed on the F5 Square
engines giving the move Bishop to E6 uh
A6 as another move as well so surprising
that she's here in this position looks
as though Nakamura has a small Edge uh
in this just spatial edge with the pawn
on C4 but nothing much to write home
about I think that Fabiano is going to
feel comfortable with the black pieces
here thank you uh Maurice I just I agree
that uh there's not much going on in the
Fabiano game at the moment uh still uh
the opening is
um evolving but in that game of uh Nei
and H Hoon this is a really really sharp
line I know that there's a lot of ideas
where black can play moves like D5 for
example uh the idea is for example if
you recapture to play a move like H5 and
undermine this Knight there are ideas of
um H5 as we saw in that previous game
with Knight takes E4 and the fact that
she's spending so much time on a
position that's very early young still
and the lines are so deep it's horri
indicates to me that uh she's just
having uh doubts about her preparation
or difficulty recalling what her
intended move was and she has made a
move and I believe she did Play Bishop
E6 after what I ter terrible yeah a
lengthy thing in a sharp theoretical
position so something not going so well
at the moment for uh huan let me return
to the game of Fabiano Karana and hikaro
Nakamura for a second so we just we just
did see this move Knight C6 now I'm
expecting castles getting your king
nicely tucked away and White's idea is
as simple as bringing his Knight to C3
and quickly anchoring it on the D5
Outpost quick shout out to uh Tammy Hyde
who does the uh Teek a here at the chess
club and the World Chess Hall of fan on
our production team doing a great job
right yeah she uh it's her birthday
happy birthday that's right happy
birthday Tam um you know it's just
amazing the staff here at the chess club
and the World Chess Hall of Fame
everybody at the chess campus as we now
call it because we've also got the
kingside diner and throwing in the other
office just uh down the street there
that Joy Bray stays in that's right I
mean it's just such a relaxed group of
work Hol that's what I love like
everybody works so hard but then it's
not like that New York or La hard work
where they got to tell you all the time
it's just like everybody's chill yeah
it's awesome lot of New York
come a lot of self good good self
motivation going on here yes but all
right so this game still uh evolving as
I mentioned and after after the the
pause for the move Bishop E6 we have
seen the move Bishop
G2 uh keeping an eye over that D5
squares to prevent
black from getting in this important
break D6 D5 and after Bishop G2 G6
attacking the Knight now interestingly
enough it's not like this Knight has to
go away uh there are a lot of games I've
seen where white does make sacrifices
but he has retre it to E3 kind of
clamping down on that D5 Square the
funny thing about the Sicilian is often
times we see a hyper tactical battle but
once in a while the tactics um emerge
and take a little turn and become a more
positional contest where it's about
squares yes squ it's a it's a sudden
fight for positional strategic uh
Outpost and I just wanted to say that I
have seen these types of sacrifices
perhaps not in this specific position
but just uh an indication uh Queen F3
and you say okay I challenge you to take
my knight if you take my knight I've
opened up this diagonal I attack this
bishop and if you go back back G5 and
it's sort of like this
initiative uh for the piece and again if
I if I drive your night away from the
board then I've got this great Outpost
right so I have seen those very typical
sacrifices in this line but 93 very
powerful move I'm not going to call it
routine but it does have a very clear
idea of I white is angling for the move
G 5 followed by uh anchoring on D5 the
difference is between this and ashikov
is sometimes well often times in Aion of
cof there's a knight on A3 that's
utterly misplaced and you take like
three or four moves to get it back into
the game in this case uh White's done
much better as both Knights are Central
centralized and uh y found responded
rather quickly with KN did C6 so amping
up the speed here she has to because she
took so long on on what was it move five
or six yeah on move eight and we got a
grandm morce actually with a an update
um on live rating list oh very good yes
uh this is 2700 chess.com you can go to
it to find all the nuances and details
behind the top players in the world and
at the top of the list is Magnus Carlson
at 2850 Nakamura and Carana at number 5
and6 on the classic list but when you go
to Rapid you'll see that in Rapid chess
again Carlson is number one Nakamura is
number two and Karana number three which
is why Nakamura says this is a difficult
battle for him in Rapid chess Karana
right behind him at number three but
when you go to Blitz chess Nakamura is
number one in the world right now with
2884 Carlson number two and you could go
down the list and you can't find fabbi
anywhere at the bottom of the list the
reason why is the bottom of this list is
actually a 20 2700 but when we go back
to see his rating in in Rapid in Blitz I
mean he's a
2665 way down the bit list in fact more
than 200 rating points below Nakamura in
blitz so today is really Fab's chance
and he's got to win maybe another game
go plus one because those eight games of
Blitz will decidedly be in nakamura's
favor at least according to the ratings
list and according to those of us who
watch Nakamura play Blitz it's hard
fighting this guy is a reason why he's
number one in the world in Blitz chess
incredibly fast incredibly resourceful
the game we just saw him lose badly
notwithstanding Nakamura does not make
those kinds of mistakes every day and
you probably won't see another one of
those for another 10 years so watch out
as far as Fab's concerned there's no
reason to get happy there's no reason
for his fans to start being elated at
all at all because Nakamura is a
dangerous beast and before this game
started he sat at the board for a full
10 minutes by himself as he collected
his thoughts and I don't know what he
was thinking but those could not have
been good thoughts for
Fabby and uh after this move Queen C8
and the and the Nakamura uh Karana match
Queen
C8 hikaro is just lashed out with the
move F2
F4 usually a move that you only want to
make it's kind of a bridge burning move
of sorts um is you take a lot of
strategic risks that you could easily
overpress and uh you don't want to get a
back word epon he he done this
doubtlessly uh for very concrete reasons
he wants to drive the Knight back from
Black's point of view black would love
to have some moves in rookie 8 Knight
Knight C5 and then we could see why this
move F4 is a strategically risky move as
white could get uh hamstrung with a
backward uh Pawn on on the E file but F4
let's say Knight back to D7 I think that
what Hikaru has in mind is first to
chase this
bishop uh onto an awkward
Square where that we make this move F4
F5 possible so uh a line either Queen
Shack followed by Knight C3 or what I
wanted to say was some kind of a line
that goes like E4 Knight C5 G4 where
you're angling for this F5 break so uh
very concrete position uh when you play
this move F4 you do it with a very clear
purpose and you don't want to
miscalculate cuz it's it you could
easily overreach uh in the position here
now mean
we we've see that uh Yan hon and Nei
yeah yeah so we've got a let's see what
happen exchanges in this position and uh
also some some ideas to expand on the
king side and get some attacks here by
Nei so uh after Knight C6 he immediately
played the move knight uh D5 I thought
he might first try to preface it with
the move G5 just to
win control of the square he did not do
that he went Knight D5
Bishop takes D5 Knight takes
D5 okay uh normally speaking uh when you
have a space edge it's nice to keep as
many pieces on the board so I might have
expected him to have played e takes D5
that was not his choice he took with the
Knight Knight takes D5 now he took with
the pawn Knight back and I suppose if
white could play a move for example like
H5 Bishop uh pardon me G5 Bishop to E4
just to clamp down on this square and to
do what you can to stop black from
playing F5 white would have a very
strategically nice game so that is
something that huifan does not want to
fall into uh a passive position so at
the moment after let me get an update on
the board for a second pardon me so
after back interestingly Nei did not
play the move H5 he kept that in reserve
he played Bishop E3 a developing move
not bad Bishop G7 Queen D2 preparing to
Castle exactly Queen
D7 now uh this uh little tickle on
against the pawn on G4 causes
white
uh I might want to re uh double guess
pardon me double guess that move Queen
D2 which just kind of at the moment the
queen on D1 nicely protects this Pawn on
G4 and again I think I would have fallen
back to the move H5 I really like
getting in that move
H5 so you think this is a real threat on
the pawn on G4 like if we Castle yes FL
can just take it without question I
think it's a very clear idea you a
healthy Pawn here well it's not that
it's just a healthy Pawn it's that
you're you're you're letting this Knight
suddenly have a square and the knight's
going to look very good on that square
and furthermore if black ever gets in F5
and E5 this piece has come to life keep
in mind this queen can uh if you try to
get a Tempo against the queen for
example Bishop H3 the queen can come
very nicely over to A4 with a
Counterattack of its own and you've you
snapped off a very important Pawn as he
has given up that pawn so that's
interesting I was wondering if he might
preface us all with Bishop H3 um to
start the day but instead he has play
Queens side castles offering this Pawn
here so let's see what he could have in
mind the only thing I can imagine
correct that's the only thing that uh
would justify his moves but now Knight
F5 now with Knight F5 Bishop H3 and she
uh H Eon captured the pawn and we have
seen the move F4 and now I yes I can
very well imagine that White's getting
uh a strong Initiative for the pawn
sacrifice but after the move F4 uh a key
question is okay I just snaap the pawn
I'm a pawn up um show me the
compensation I'll drop back I probably
start by taking you on IFI okay and I'll
recapture with the bishop and thank
thank you that you've opened up this
diagonal for me that's true so I can win
back my Pawn now with Bishop takes H six
but that's
right we get a position where now maybe
I can get some kind of initiative over
here on the queen side perhaps Rook C8
but let me just go over here and Par my
queen uh in some kind of menacing
situation so that again what I'm seeing
is that blacks going to have pretty good
minor pieces on E5 and F5 and white
didn't have to allow anything uh even
close to this and um losing control I
would I would say maybe after Queen B7
we can play a bishop H3 instead I'm
sorry so after Queen goes back now
Bishop H3
and I'll do the similar thing right
gaining a Tempo again very important
Tempo that's very nice Pawn you don't if
black captures that pawn then suddenly
the white king is a little is more than
unhappy you'd have to probably play King
B1 and then again look for a
justification as to why and you can open
up you can open up the situation too it
takes a for at your moment or or E4 but
instead actually Yan decided to uh
Castle so inad retreating the queen but
that's that's a little surprising
because now where a queen can end up a
less enticing position if I play Bishop
H3 now like I I I liked the queen
landing on A4 as you demonstrated all
these
variations um unless she can just snack
on another pond that's uh as greedy as I
am I think that's a little bit too want
that pond oh man when I decline ponds uh
it's got to be really really bad
cupcakes if I'm not going to it that way
it's kind of similar right right so hold
on but now having said that if I don't
capture on H4 and I'm not uh at all
pleased with that where else can I put
my queen if I put my queen on G3 let's
try G3 for a moment Jen am I afraid of
F5 or not that's a key question well I
can also can I preface things with just
do G1 also yes this one because you
don't want to leave the the bishop
hanging but it seems like that's a
useful but so here I can also consider
I'm considering H5 and
F5 yeah I just have the feeling that
castling and giving up the address of
the king uh was a little bit premature I
would have dropped my queen back okay we
are where we are how are you handling
this bishop G2 D5 is hanging by the way
right okay so um after Queen F3 I was
okay you can play Bishop G2 I guess uh
Queen H5 uh this is murky there's a lot
of possibilities here I'm going to turn
it over to you does the computer think
that this was a good Pawn sacrifice I
have my doubts actually the engines uh
do believe that this was a very good
sacrifice okay very good maybe
overstating it feels it's fine that this
is fine for white the two Bishops will
speak the spatial Advantage there is
basic equality compensation for white
for giving away this pawn and just needs
to be solid that Queen Retreats you
talking about yes King B1 was the
suggested idea it's just white has space
and the Bishops and it looks as though
the Bishops are potentially effective in
this position so after F4 castles was a
move and Bishop H3 the engine saying
Queen H5 it's a good home for the queen
on H5 looks like it might be a scary
place to be but here in just saying no
problem in fact instead of that move Nei
has gone for it with the move H5 hello
keep it crazy I think he's starting to
feel himself a little bit now that in
Wild chest he might have the edge
instead of keeping it smooth especially
not giving her the initiative we see
what she's like when she has the
initiative she will thp you on the head
like boom and now it looks like he is
saying in Rapid chess his his strategy
is take the initiative at all cost play
a little bit while play Creative don't
worry about analyzing too much I think
that is the way the formula for this
stuff don't worry about too much
precision as long as you're not not lost
if it looks crazy do it and I his
creativity is definitely showing here I
should point out by the way that in this
position in this opening back here in
the opening she had one of her great
victories in tata steel and her young
career she beat uh his countryman panan
Nei his countryman pentala Hari Krishna
she played him and Tata steel back in
2013 and she won with the black pieces
so a little bit of Revenge man on the
mine for Nei having played Knight F5 in
that game however she played Knight C6
which is the main move Bishop E6 she
played has only been played once so
maybe she's smelled a rat in that
position there now we're talking about
that this game is crazy after H5 the
other game is also gone nuts and look at
how far down the line they are here I
don't remember where you guys jumped in
last I think it was F4 right way back
here look how much action has
proceeded since then after Knight D6 C6
and a trade Knight C3 Knight E7 E4 F6
and F5 in response to that move G5 back
and then C5 I mean wild chest happening
in this game this idea of C5 it looks
like takes is on uh in the position but
the move E5 is on tap oh boy barn burner
you're talking about here C5 maybe H3
first and then C5 but I mean then E5
then Rook d8 Queen to E3 Queen D7 H3
chasing the bishop back burying it and
then E5 an amazing move opening up the
line for this bishop also for the Knight
on e4 the pawn was captured Bishop B7
Rook B8 Rook ad D1 I'm jumping ahead
just because we need to catch up with
these guys Bishop F3 Rook to B4 a trade
and now Rook to D1 and now he played
Rook to to
D4 so after all that the engines are
saying Edge for white but wow lots of
crazy moves you can't blink and you know
when we do commentary we get all these
classic games and you can sort of look
around and look at nuances the moment
you do that 20 moves have been rattled
off in the other game so this is where
we are as we stand now an exciting
position indeed in both games as game
three this is a critical game W the one
who wins this will really feel
themselves in Nakamura they trading on
the D4 square and the game continues
yeah I was just looking at Rook takes D4
e takes D4 Queen D3 pitting the pawn to
the queen and White's idea is very
straightforward hikaro would like to
play Knight E2 capture this pawn and be
a very solid Pawn up after Queen D3 what
happened Queen to
D7 and again the natural question to ask
is what are we we going to do after 92 I
guess the answer is going to be kn6 so
he's hoping to maybe get some dark
Square I mean light Square weaknesses
here and he doesn't lose a pawn because
after Bishop takes ween takes his Scot
well you could take the other way though
right pardon me I be you pardon at this
point you could take what the queen as
well I yes so after Queen takes C6 there
the queen takes D4 but I'm wondering now
maybe the light squares offer some
compensation after this move Queen F3
and Bishop and so yeah some compensation
a lot
I don't think I don't think you're going
to invite that yeah you're just winning
back you're just winning back material
immediately right CU we can't play
that's true you're winning back this
Pawn on
H3 no no I don't think this is uh what
Hikaru has in mind there's there may be
something on with the queenside majority
but no I think that after Queen D7
Knight E2 Knight C6 now having said that
there is this very annoying threat of
Knight E5 as well as Bishop d 5 if black
is able to maintain his pass Pawn on D4
it could very quickly turn from
liability to asset that's right so it
has to be very precise here does Hikaru
and his bad play in the previous game
makes his fans nervous well maybe he'll
be okay in the variation after Bishop C6
Knight C6 Knight D4 Queen C5 Queen E3
with a bunch of threats guarding
everything where has some thoughts on
the other game up just have to jump in
really fast before it happens uh it
looks like something dramatic well at
least something important for the the
the match is going on right now after H5
she played Knight to F5 attacking the
bishop Bishop to H3 was played and now
Queen takes H5 boldly going along the
same line as this rook and now Bishop
back to G2 and she played Queen G4 only
move and now he's put his Bishop back on
H3 so so it looks as though a repetition
may happen on this board and this game
May end in a quiet draw I don't think we
can say quiet draw is that fair well
after all the fireworks the players have
given us I I can imagine they want a
little bit of a respit and okay you know
wasn't plan they were both they were for
it no and especially this this double
Pawn sacrifice but that was curious to
me so he so H5 was played Knight jumped
out to F5 and the problem for White's
point of view is white would love to get
in this H takes G6 the problem is Knight
takes E3 captures a bishop and forces
white uh to sacrifice a piece and that
was why we saw Nei playing Bishop H3 but
now Queen takes a H5 and for the moment
Black's King is beautifully uh sheltered
a lot of protection for Black's King and
that's why I think we're seeing this
repetition uh because uh Nei uh because
black king is simply so very well
defended uh a little discretion is the
better part of valor here now meanwhile
the other game we've got a couple of
moves updated so Nakamura instead of
playing Knight to E2 has played a played
the started with the quieter move King
F2 since the pin is still maintained and
now after H5 um we imagine he's probably
going to play Knight E2 and how does
that change things if any um if we look
at the same position with uh the King on
F2 instead of on uh G1 well maybe black
is going to throw in takes on G4 because
otherwise we're we always have the
option of taking on H5 right I'm not so
sure you're worried too much about G
takes H5 I think there's Knight E5 in
the position Jen that uh you got to keep
a careful watchful ey we take on C6
again like Bishop takes Queen takes now
so before when we play Queen before we
had to worry about Queen F3 right so now
there's no Queen F3 but there is Queen
H1 which is equally annoying
unfortunately for white uh this Pawn on
H3 and there's even checks to be
considered um I'm just going to say
compensation I I can't believe it's uh
bad for black to have such an active
queen with the King exposed so let's do
night so we could do Knight D4 again
though okay let's go back a move or two
so we were here and you were saying
Knight oop sorry I apologize Knight
takes D4
here yeah so Knight D4 you you have this
queen C5 mole which I'll happily play as
it does put the knight in a little
awkward pin you don't have time you're
not able to part if i c p E3 though I'm
threatening Knight E6 with a with a pin
and I maybe I'll play night6 no matter
what okay so a bit of uncertainty by the
way by Nakamura in the last move we saw
him reach for that move and then pull
his hand back as though somebody slapped
it and then he looked again trying to
figure out what to do and now he's
finally play this move Queen to E4 and
he looks not so sure you know how clear
he is with his emotional state and
there's something going on that he's not
too thrilled with some lack of clarity
right now but he's he's trying to keep
very calm here but he knows the money
time has come we need to take a look at
the clocks as well as they are now in
pure Blitz mode it's five minutes left
on the clock H for him and now kn5 and
now he snapped the pawn off the board he
is now ahead by one Pawn in the position
for the moment Knight E5 Queen takes
D4 and again I will say compensation but
it was much clearer compensation when
there was a queen on H1 the uh now it's
not that clear to me so for example if
black plays a move like Queen B5
obviously avoiding being uh a trade of
Queens
um I've got ideas here I've got ideas
I've got Knight C3 this looks like a
very nice nice move this is an Ending by
the way I would be very happy to play
with white because uh first of all the
king is much more active second of all
these Targets on A7 and C7 quite
promising for white so I think uh the
inclusion of this move King F2 was very
crafty by
hikaro and nice move Queen E4 boldly
pointing out the obvious by the way
D3 Queen takes C6 Queen takes C6 Bishop
takes C6 D2 does not get you a new Queen
because of Knight C3 Maurice big
development in the other game she
decided to go for it check this out
let's repeat moves after Queen H5 Bishop
G2 looked like one of those GM
repetitions and how you fun said you you
know what I don't think so I'm going to
allow my knight to be pinned on the H
file even though she is ahead by two
pawns she said I don't care even Bishop
F2 is in the position by the way Bishop
F2 would be answered by Bishop F6 that
sort of a torturous defensive setup that
you probably would not play but the
engine saying this is fine for her as
well she can defend his position
although white has compensation but take
a look at what he did Knight H4 telling
him I want to win and he said well I
want to win too F5 out of nowhere
throwing this Pawn down the board he's
now got pressure on this line as well
remember the pin is there forever he's
trying to open up the black king side
she responded quietly with the move G5
very solid controlling her Knight now
the only problem is her Knight is in a
terrible place and he's play the move
Rook over to G1 the engines like the
move Bishop to E4 right away by the way
Bishop to E four instead he's played
Rook to G1 and she can now play F6 and
if this happens it looks like it looks
like Bishop F2 is going to be coming
soon I don't know yes
F5 G5 Rook hg1 Fighting Chess on these
boards no draw and look at the clock she
only has about 30 seconds left 40 make
it 43 now that she's getting increments
can you believe she avoided the
repetition this sane spent all that time
burned all that clock to just go into an
unclear position that that just seems
insane him having the edge and she looks
about as calm as if she was reading a
book in the library I mean it's like
nothing to her right now despite the
fact that she is in horrific time
pressure you got to love the heart but I
don't think I love the position I mean I
she's very brave she's very brave indeed
I think a lot of grand Masters would
have been very happy to take the
repetition in that particular particular
position and she's facing some serious
challenges uh from a positional point of
view white gets to play Bishop E4 the
two pawns that she sacri that's been
sacrificed well they'll probably play
dividends Bishop F2 is very annoying
every almost all of her pieces and this
is not a fun position to play when you
only have 30 seconds on the clock
because most of her pieces are pened or
paralyzed yes so G5 Rook G and what what
move did she play after Rook G1 she
played King h8 she played King h so
we're expecting a a solid move let's
call it with Bishop E4 uh just bringing
that Bishop uh and that is what happened
so n Bishop E4 stopping E5 E4 protecting
this Pawn on F5 and white intends to one
day not immediately but to play Bishop
F2 double those pawns and that was why
we saw huifan getting her King out of
this potentially open G file and it
looks like Bishop F6 was played is that
right yeah I think I see Bishop F6 I see
a bishop F6 okay so these this queen and
this Knight are very awkwardly placed
it's not going to be at all easier you
always have to watch out for Rook H4
with the idea that if Queen H4 there's a
rook H1 but of course the bishop F2 just
Cal and collected yeah just just keeping
everything Frozen on the king side now
having said that it's not like this
queen on D2 can go over here too too
soon because there's Queen E2 in the
position so a lot a sharp position let's
get back to weird ideas like Bishop F3
queen queen F3 Rook takes H4 suddenly
we're coming in with the The Mating on
H6 type so I mean there's some weird
little cheapos there but all the cheapos
are are in White's territory that's for
you yeah okay let's go back to our uh
main match we've got uh we left it oops
let me I'm still going
backwards uh
left the guys have more time on their
clock because they played a lot more
moves I mean that's a pattern we see so
that's why yon and Nei are down to just
like a minute and half a minute and
we've got almost uh almost eight minutes
on this match a very big surprise for me
was this move Bishop E8 by Fabiano I
thought okay that we got the same ending
where he's a pawned down I thought it
was very important for him to get act an
active queen queen E1 uh with the idea
of Queen F1 and picking up this Pawn on
H3 he didn't do that he played Bishop E8
King F2 lots of moves have been played
so I'm playing catch up with the players
Bishop C6 Knight E2 and
now uh very nice uh comfortable extra
Pawn for white uh strong Bishop on D5
it's not all on one one goal but it sure
looks like uh he Haru has done very well
and uh has a
promising make up for for yesterday for
earlier meanwhile we got to got to
switch back over toan Nei because this
position is very exciting and they both
have only about 30 seconds left in their
clock oh my goodness um Nei burnt up a
lot of time in this exact position even
though um he only plays the uh the most
natural move Bishop F2 you got to think
he's pound out yes pounded that one out
a bit faster and now uh we see um Rook
G8 from yon and I somehow want to try to
attack that Queen on H5 I was mentioning
earlier I was going to try to play
Bishop F3 at the right moment thinking
that if Queen F3 I have Rook H4 one of
the problems with that little tactic is
that there's also night case available
because my queen is hanging on D2 so we
have seen this uh tucking the king in
King B1 Rook
G7 boy I think
huifan doesn't realize what's actually
uh happened here these pieces this queen
on H5 and this Knight on F4 are totally
frozen and she's clearly playing for
Rook G7 Rook G8 and one day to play G4 I
think uh she's about to discover that
after a move like Queen E1 there's
simply no play any further play
whatsoever on the king side and that
Queen is not deliciously placed either I
mean attack that Bishop guys yes the
clock is ticking down and he has to find
a move he will he play Queen E1 but look
at the other game because that one's
flying as well lots of moves play there
and now it looks as though he took a
pawn did Nakamura but Queen takes C5 now
the C Pawn is gone from the board to
engines saying that the position is
currently fine for black well slight
Edge for white still despite the pawn
advantage in that position so that one
is very interesting interesting but
Nakamura has more time we've got to get
back to the other game that's right so
Queen B4 so they're they're playing on
increment I think both games are playing
on increment no the other game has a lot
has a lot of time got like five well a
lot being a relative term minutes these
guys are literally playing on increment
here she's just blundered she's just
blundered Queen takes D6 Queen and queen
take well he went Queen B4 sorry uh
Maurice Queen B4 A6 Queen B4 Queen E2
Des to get active exactly and then Queen
takes D6 and give me the pawn and give
me your Bishop on F6 has been played
Queen takes E4 and now now and now he
played Rook takes H4 so damn Rook takes
H4 this was the tactic that you wanted
Jen with the idea that after takes Queen
takes F6 and G takes H4 Queen takes F6
has been played Rook G8 has been played
and now Nei has at least a Perpetual if
he wants it perpetual
no this one is over this one is just
simple tactics rip the pawn off first of
all then go back with cck and then it's
going to be his dark Square Bishop
coming into the game probably this has
happened this has yes this has happened
and I think Bishop H4 is not winning
right now oh and D6 will come as well
what what would what would you do a D6
King H7 is the only idea for her to be
able to take to be able to play King H7
to un pin so we have to respect that
idea Queen repeated moves just just to
catch up gaining time on the clock he
can do one more time since the last time
there was actually a pawn there so he
can he can play one more right without
it being three moves but now he's got to
play a different move if he wants to
continue the game but exactly boy it's
not easy with just 10 seconds left on
the clock um is he going to well it's
time to play A4 or something oh D6 he
has reached for so he is definitely
playing for the wi W what heart both
players are showing in this game but
that move that move does not work
unfortunately because of King H7 we had
talked about this King H7 actually the
winning move was Bishop E3 almost
impossible to spot in this time pressure
but now it looks like she has saved
herself she is back in the game Rook e
has been played and not D1 I apologize
Rook still I mean still you got you got
to say that there's almost always going
to be um minimum some kind of Perpetual
or idea for white it's hard I understand
nei's just trying to make some moves and
show the power of His pieces here well
I'm guessing Bishop well no Bishop B6
I'm not H what has he did ooh Rook H1
and he overlooked a back ranked mate
Rook
unbelievable ouch Rook H1 he thought he
was just winning because he was going to
pick up this Pawn with check but look at
this I said he needed to just throw in
A4 or A3 or any kind of move you even
thought he did at some point I did and
then suddenly comes this check and oops
he has resigned the game uh overlooking
that there's a very brutal back rank
Checkmate she didn't she didn't take too
long to see that she played that in like
a mill yeah she was
ready that's when you double your Rooks
on the G file in those situations you're
looking the tragedy of it all by the way
is that after Rook E1 Queen F4 is a
mistake on her part she should have
played Rook G1 right away talk about a
spectacular move Rook G1 would have
forced him to Propet with Queen F7
that's the only thing he could have done
here but instead after Queen F4 he could
have just simply played simply sorry
with all the time pressure it's hard to
say but he could have gone for this line
and this one is overwhelming because of
this Pawn this would have been a
tremendous position for him too bad it
did not work and now he has lost the
game a devastating loss for him I don't
see him recovering from that one that's
terrible but now we have to jump to the
other game the Nakamura game where
Nakamura has a pass outside Pawn uh an
outside pass Pawn but the bishop on E2
is harassing that pawn on G4 is it
enough to win the engines not giving
that dramatic an edge for white not even
giving a pawn Edge which means that
normally this will be compensation so
this one still in the balance wow
awesome performance by both players in
that game in my opinion I mean sure they
both got short on time and they both
made mistakes but a lot of heart I mean
the thing is the quality is obviously
going to be overall lower when you play
at Sicilian because it requires because
it requires more from both players yes
there's a lot more stress the tension in
the position you have to be so precise
almost every single move can flip the
advantage to the other side you're
squeezing a lot more drama into 15
minutes and you would be if you played a
quiet line we exchange queens and the
opportunity to blenders are smaller
right but let's head back to Nakamura
Carana and see if anything interesting
is going on there the problem for white
is is that his pieces are tied to the
defense of this Pawn on G4 and it's not
easy for White's King to come over and
release the knight from the defense of
the Pawn on G4 and in the meanwhile you
can use this Pawn on A5 as a decoy to
try to get your king to E6 but uh
Fabiana is going to stop that I believe
with the move Bishop F3 let me just get
up to date with the players I do believe
A4 is the last move Okay so Bishop F3
has been played so now here's the
question uh if he how do I get this so
that I get to go King C5 to D6 I don't
know I was I was thinking A5 let me just
put on the board what I was thinking of
playing was something of this type if I
can use my a pawn as a decoy and to get
my king to D6 and either E6 and pick up
these pawns if I do that I win yes he's
got Bishop E2 right now Bishop E2 and
he's still okay engine saying that any
other move other than Bishop E2 is fatal
you must play Bishop E2 right now and
you're still fine but white is in some
kind of semi zwang he can't really
improve the position and he has found it
the only move on the board Bishop to E2
White's Knight cannot move White's Pawn
cannot advance that means the king will
have to see ground in the center and
allow Black's King to come up so this
move Bishop E2 looks like the Saving
Grace King to C3 will be answer by King
to C5 and it looks like he's fine all
right let me just uh double check on
that I definitely agree that Bishop E2
was the only move because if the king
had gone after the a pawn then there was
a path to the F6 Pawn but
King if I go King E2
uh King D2 questioning the bishop on E2
uh I supposing the bishop will maintain
its um vigilant attack on the pawn on
G4 I guess I've got to go all the way
back like this but then I eventually
will be able to pick up the a pawn
without having lost my F6 Pawn so it
looks like a draw it is a draw it looks
like every move leads to a draw right
now Nakamura is going to have to go in
trickster mode to try to get his
opponent to make a mistake but it
doesn't what is the times uh we' got got
30 yeah I mean well nakamura's always
got a trickster he's he's always in
trick hey that's that's a compliment by
the way you play chess in Brooklyn in
the Parks man you got nothing left in
the position you've got to find some
kind of trick and that's where he is
right now he's looking for something
saying is there something I can do to
bother this guy that he might slip up
and make a mistake and we've seen we saw
it happen just now with Nei against how
you fun she took a loss position turning
into a win off one little trick Queen F4
and he dropped Rook G1 so hey it it's a
possibility when you're playing this
kind of rapid chess you need it you need
something but I know you can look at him
and tell that he's not too confident
about the position but somehow he has
managed to pick off the F6 pawn and now
he did play A6 by the way Bishop takes
A6 Knight came to D5 and Bishop uh swoop
back to E2 Knight takes
F6 and King I believe went to D6 D6 it's
still a draw it's definite a draw now
that King just blocking the the white
king from entering the position and the
Knight unfortunately has to guard the G
Pawn that's right and when we play King
E7 we it'll result in some
simplifications Knight E4 check and now
the Knight comes back to defend but this
shouldn't last long Knight E4 check King
came back to
E7 KN F2 well now King F6 the
simplification bishop takes G4 King E4
so King E4 a little bit of a zong right
now because black has to move it looks
like black has to move the bishop
somewhere wait a minute this looks like
this could get interesting now just
Bishop apparently just Bishop back lots
of moves actually surprisingly but
Bishop back let's say to A6 for example
should be just fine it doesn't look as
though there are any moves here and then
King E3 to uh Menace Knight E4 King it
E5 Knight
E4 Bishop F pardon me Bishop C8 to
capture Big Time threat of trading off
right that's for a minute there it
looked like uh the trickster mode almost
had it but Bishop C8 to sacrifice the
Bish he did find Bishop A6 and there
goes the maneuver that you're talking
about yes Bishop B7 check to Chase the
king away the white king cannot Venture
away from those pawns exactly I think
Fab's got this completely under control
he knows exactly what's going on this
game should be a draw but again it's
it's those ghosts you want you want to
create ghosts as many ghosts did did his
hand look like nakamura's hand extended
momentarily there looking for a
move and again I don't see the times of
the players very well 146 to 36 1 minute
and 4 seconds that's plenty of time for
hikaro my goodness the greatest bullet
player ever has a minute and 30 seconds
he's fine that's like having two years
two years from with no sorry it's not
bullet it's B it's plus increment Inc
what are you kidding no there's not a
chance now he's just retreated King the
king3 king's F you're anticipating King
E5 he did play King E5 right now I think
the dangerous pass once you play Knight
H3 this whole Bishop C8 or Bishop D3 for
that matter uh and just simply capturing
this Pawn that will be dead dead draw it
looks like zong as a matter of fact
where is he what is he going to do he
just brought his Knight backwards to D1
Knight to
D1 he's trying to prevent this uh attack
this pardon me the sacrifice but with
this active King no way what about a
check right now doesn't doesn't a check
on
B7 he's actually played the the piece
there and shacked him chased him over
and now it's definitely a draw yes yeah
now now his Knight cannot move his King
has to guard against King F4 it looks
like actually he might be able to get
the pawn to F6 if you're not
careful so uh Bishop D3 was the next
move yeah Bishop D3 just uh marking
time I don't see King H3 King to H3
where are you going he's just making
moves he just making moves he he wants
anything to happen just want to see what
are you going to do next but seriously
he'll just move as Bishop D4 yeah yeah
Bishop E4 looks like a very good choice
a very good choice
indeed I think everybody would do that
and I don't know if Hikaru is trying to
triangulate or something I just don't
see why it makes a difference so Bishop
uh Bishop E2 instead sorry after King
everything draws here Bishop E2 W Pike
right okay so no King F6 was also
possible by the way just keeping an eye
on the pawn because the white king is
now white king went from the middle of
the board to H3 like think about that
Journey MH certainly not going to do
anything and I think Nakamura
is recognizing now that he's got nothing
Carana by the way remember that first
game he drew the first game by torturing
Nakamura remember that we said let's get
a little bit in his head a little
psychology work his brain a little bit
and then that then he won the second
game and now he's saying yeah you had an
edge but no big deal now I'm able to
draw again so certainly he's got to be
feeling a bit confident as much as
Nakamura wants to flip this around and
torture him it's not enough torture here
he just too comfortable and he knows it
look at that King now onto the F4 Square
allowing the f want to go down the board
one step but I don't think it's going to
want to go there I had wanted to ask uh
is F6 such a frightening uh move and the
simple answer is no it's not after
Bishop G6 the king is threatening to
come back to E5 uh to round up that pawn
and if you go Knight here sure you can
win the
bishop but that's what white what black
wants to do anyway a draw now guys it
looks like that's happening in fact we
are getting one of these lines on the
board I see and boy are the
players and draw and nakam just
immediately leave this flee the seene I
think he was really psychologically
wanting to win into this game to erase
the memory of game to and that was only
like a semi eraser you really wanted to
like completely forget about that game
yeah the the horrible horrible game yes
but he has one more chance he does with
the black pieces though and Fabiano
looks confident did you see the
relaxation in his in his body the way he
was just playing like come on dude you
know this is a draw no big deal and I
think he's he's got even know I hate
using the word momentum too much because
he one of those things that just flips
instantly and then we're saying momentum
for the other guy but it just he just
looks so much more relaxed right now
very confident happy to have tied up the
match and now he gets the white pieces
going to the next game exactly let's
take a look and see the uh the results
that three runs of Rapid had shown us
well Nakamura has got one point in the
rapid and carolana has two Naka was a
point ahead in the match before the
rapid so it's not tight the match is
tight however in the other match in the
other match it's been a lot of fun but
even more fun for Hoon who leads 21 and
was also a point ahead in the overall
match so now leads by two points and
this will be a fun game if we judge by
their previous ones they've been real um
exciting
gamesis G except for the first one not
as exciting but the last couple have
just been brilliant right and and poor
Nei in that last game he will really Ru
that Ru the moment that he allowed that
Rook G1 because he really played a fine
game and was sacrificing pawns and had
built up a very be and when he the
moment he played Rook H4 I'm sure he
just thought okay sign the score sheet
the game's over and who you f onc Rook
G1 for fighting till the end that's what
you got to do especially in Rapid and
Blitz so we are going to be back from St
Louis Showdown for the last game in the
rapid battle
[Music]
wonderful
so we're going to have a tandem chess
match today it's not the most common
type of Chess but Rex is pretty
experienced at this basically there's a
two versus two match where one side
playing the white pieces will be playing
alternatively so Rex will play one move
then Fabiana will play the next one and
then it goes back to Rex same with the
black pieces now the interesting part is
that the partners cannot actually talk
about chess with each other so the team
is only as strong as its weakest link
it's not quite as good but it's it's not
the end of the
[Music]
world we got something the conversation
around baseball managing is thinking so
many steps ahead and you guys are so
many moves ahead and that you've already
memorized so many different strategies
um it it's it it it's mastering a crap
that's Grand Master is a great great
name for it and just something that I
have a great deal of respect for i' like
to recognize a very special guest that
is with us this evening James Vernon a
retiree and army veteran was leading a
chess class with 16 children in
attendance class was interrupted when a
young knife wielding fellow entered the
room and made his intention that he
intended to take some lives he
distracted the man told the kids to run
to safety and they all made it out
safely the knife wielding man tried to
attack Mr Vernon but his army skills
kicked in and he held him off and
although he suffered some lacerations he
subdued the man and held him for the
authorities Mr Vernon you are truly one
of the toughest chess teachers I've had
the
[Applause]
meion when something must be done
risk risk injury do it thank you all
very
[Music]
[Applause]
much
[Music]
for
Blitz really
is and welcome back
to round four of the Rapids and boy the
players blitzing between Hikaru Nakamura
and Fabiana Karana looks like it's an E4
French E4 E6 D4 D5 Knight C3 Knight F6
E5 Knight D7 F4 so a main line steinet
and let me see if I'm up to date with
the players yet we've seen a lot of end
games in Caron and nakura by the way so
this more closed treatment maybe it's
going to be the first one that we're
going to see more more of a middle game
more of a middle game we've been seeing
lots of exciting middle games in the
other match between who yon and uh Nei
but you're right a lot of end games here
not much in the way of cting middle game
attack still exciting end games and
imbalances and but not not the slashers
that we've been seeing and youan Nei now
speaking of that match we've seen many
Sicilians but instead of going for the
open Sicilian in which she um with
Knight F3 and Knight 64 well Nei got the
better hand in in the best game um of of
the match so far I think from either
match right with the bishop A2 check
sacrifice lovely I mean and The Rook C8
move so she decided to not repeat that
of course you would want to repeat the
whole game but she went for Queen takes
D4 which also leads to some nice
attacking chances for white with very
little Theory yeah comparison to kn4 I'm
sorry I just was stalled there because
I'm trying to think usually they have
the inclusions of Knight F3 and Knight
F6 in right and I'm wondering who who
does it favor that Knight F6 and Knight
F3 are not in the position I'm thinking
that maybe it favors black because of
Knight C6 and the usual move is Bishop
B5 but in this case E6 and maybe the
Knight can swing over here to E7 and
play for A6 and try to win the two
Bishops in a very nice way well let's
just catch up something else actually
that perhaps it was good for black
because normally black uh White likes to
play with C4 against some of Black's
moves like A6 and Bishop D7 and you've
already committed right now we've
already played Knight C3 so maybe just
A6 or Bishop D7 as well but it doesn't
look like that's what Nei chose in fact
he chose to take it um along the
mainstream waters for well as mainstream
as Queen takes D4 is going to get with
Bishop D7 provoking Bishop takes C6
Bishop takes C6 Knight F3 E6 and now
Bishop G5 I would imagine is a standard
move which
hon has played and uh now let's take a
look at where these players stand after
three rounds of a rapid well in Basque
chess Yan lost O2 but she rebounded in a
major way in Fisher random earning three
and a half points out of a possible four
and in Rapid chess she's ahead of the
game as well with two out of three so
Nei really in the defensive here he's
got three and a half against yon's 5 and
a half and he's is going to have to show
some massive skills in this game and
also tomorrow in the blitz where they
play Eight Games kowana meanwhile who
many thought was I think pretty much
everyone thought was the underdog in
this match not because so much of the
rapid but because of the other match the
other matches the Fisher random and the
Blitz and so he can be pretty pleased so
far with his even score and he's also
shown to be very confident when
defending worse positions and that's an
important skill to have against kn
kamora who really likes to pounce on you
when you show Fear exactly and uh also a
big confidence builder for Fabby uh to
be leading in the rapid chess which is
the closest if you will to uh classical
and uh Hikaru said that uh in Rapid he
didn't feel like he had such a big Edge
as he has in the other formats and let's
just see what has happened in that uh
French defense game so after
A6 follow up with B5 castles Queen B6
trades on C5 Bishop C5 Bishop C5 Knight
C5 and the normal routine play I would
say for white here is to play the move
King H1 and essentially what white is
really hoping is that black is going to
Castle his King over on the king side so
that white gets to play these moves F5
and tries to play uh for a uh kingside
attack with the move F6 so for example
one horrible way of losing if you want
to lose is to take the knight uh hello
dark squares hello dark squares and
check it mate is inevitable these guys
obviously will not fall for that but I'm
just saying uh this is what white aims
for another idea for white is to take
command of the D4 square is to bring the
swing the Knight back to E2 and swing
the Knight to D4 and just uh blockade
Black's Pawn on D5 now white has
actually already played the move Queen
F2 and Nakamura true to the match has
offered a trade of Queens with Knight
D7 but in this instance what do you
think uh I mean we're pinned so we can't
actually move our Queen at this moment
right so I'm a little disappointed with
the move Queen F2 I suppose that he's
going to fall back on the positional
plan of just going and control
controlling the D4 Square so for example
Knight E2 Queen F2 not that that's Force
by the way Rook
F2 uh King E7 Bishop B7 Knight B6 not
100% sure what black should do but let
me just choose one of them and I do like
I do prefer White's position this Knight
on D4 is really uh quite a beast and um
it's it makes it very difficult for for
black to activate his pieces especially
the bishop on C8 but wouldn't we prefer
to have all these positional trumps and
a kingside attack if we could actually
have our Queens on the board that's
right I would not I'm greedy I'd like to
have it all and uh to keep the
initiative with having the Queens yes
cuz against such a strong player as
Nakamura you're going to need more than
a pretty Knight on D4 to win the game
that's the problem like that's the start
of it but nothing going to be likely to
hold if if that's all you have to write
home about exactly but on the other hand
again I think it would be a real
confidence booster for Fabiano to win
this particular discipline in this uh
showdown in St Louis of uh rapid chess
he'll
be
chuffed chuffed that's that's a word
British word uh with such a victory and
king7 was when Nakamura played in this
position instead of no instead of taking
an actor right away he just played the
move King E7 no way are you sure with
the queen on the board he played King E7
but that allows that allows no no but
Knight E2 didn't happen oh jeez yeah
that's a problem I was about to say hold
on you're allowing M to keep the Queens
no so KN so after after Knight D7 it
looks like uh Fabby played A3
A2
A3 okay and that precipitated King e wow
A3 no of course yeah after night
E2
is like Splat right it's horrible end of
story you know s so instead Queen takes
B6 trade has been done Knight takes
B6 and now Knight E2 to occupy the
square Knight E2 well I'm not 100% sure
why uh Fabby felt it was necessary to
trade queens and activate Black's Knight
Knight Black's Knight on B6 may not be
that
great but um
it's better on B6 than it is on D7 and
I'm going to take us over to Maurice
actually on the other game yes let's
take a look at this game I've gone
pulled out the database to see the
opening the way it went and the line of
course we talked about C takes D4 Queen
takes D4 not the most common way to play
the opening uh as you know Knight F3 and
Knight takes D4 is normal Knight C6
Bishop to B5 Bishop D7 takes takes
Knight F3 now E6 and now Bishop to G5
White plays pure piece play here quickly
bringing pieces into the game but after
Knight F6 castles Bishop to E7 and now
this move Queen D3 it is a move in this
position in this just this case if I go
to the online database it shows that
Rook H E1 is the big move here this move
bringing the Rook over to the middle
most natural move most anybody would
play that move most players but Queen to
D3 getting the queen from in the middle
of the board preparing to bring a knight
to D4 a more specific idea in the
position to challenge this Bishop's
presence on the C6 Square Nei thought
for a moment here spent a bit of time
before he finally played the move Queen
to B6 now this move if I go again to the
database uh just just again the online
database here Queen B6 is not the most
common move the most common move is
Queen A5 remember the idea is Knight D4
right you with a queen on A5 you're
aggressing the bishop on the G5 Square
Queen B6 does nothing to deal with this
idea of Knight to D4 so this in this
position Knight to D4 can be played so
this one much less common it has been
played many times but much less common
than the queen A5 move which is the big
main line so let's see whether or not
this is imprecise allowing her to get
what she wants I'm going to jump to the
main board now and after Queen B6 she
actually hasn't moved as yet she might
have anticipated Queen A5 but now with
this move surprising her Knight D4 is
possible but actually the Pawn's being
hit on F2 so she played Rook H to F1
guarding that pawn now it's back to the
story of Knight to D4 let's see if his
move Queen B6 really matters and changes
the position any guys thank you Maurice
and in our game uh our fourth fourth
round game we can see that uh Fabiano is
nursing this Knight coming to D4 what he
wants to do is really uh have that
Knight
um alone like you can't touch it so to
speak so one of the things that that uh
hikaro has to be careful about is that
this Knight on B6 just doesn't end up
getting uh becoming a bit of a spectator
not playing a role uh a common tactic in
these uh positions is this move Knight
C4 the idea is that after well let's
start with if you capture uh black is
happy to uh initiate this trade of
Knight for Bishop as the Bish white
Bishop is trapped and if you go Knight
E4 Knight D4 pardon me then Knight C6
and the big
fight a big battle over the D4 Square uh
takes place the Knight on B6 is a just a
little bit um misplaced also this Knight
can maybe not such a fancy way can also
uh contest for the C6 squar by Knight C8
to
A7 having said that uh if you're black
and you say well I don't want to just
sit there and passively defend but I
want to do something that's really
aggressive and active one of the things
that black could try to do is play moves
like
H6 bring his Rook over to G8 I'll
eventually get there and play for G5
it's a very sharp idea that I remember
Alexander chernin in fenni barv uh big
French defense players playing it on
black site
and
Maurice just a small tactic worth noting
by the way you might ask the question
well if Queen A5 was meant to stop this
Knight D4 idea right away then Queen B6
didn't do it because you can still play
Knight to D4 at least so it seems
however the problem is there's a tactic
in this position beginning Bishop takes
on e4 out of nowhere and now you wonder
well what's going on well after Knight
takes Knight takes on e4 and the bishop
on G5 is hanging to the bishop on E7
well you might want to solve this
problem here problem is Knight takes F2
into meso before taking on E7 and now
suddenly this is hanging and all three
of White's majors are also hanging and
there's no real good move here because
if something like Queen to G3 Knight
takes on D1 threatening B2 as well the
queen threatening on B2 the Knight on D4
is hanging and white is in trouble in
this line black is completely winning so
that's why Queen B6 also plays prophylax
against the move Knight to D4 which is
why the move Rook to F1 happened and now
he has played the move Rook to C8 the
last time he played Rook C8 he blew her
off the board so very active player is
Nei with the Sicilian you got to be
impressed by the way he's handling these
Sicilians last game notwithstanding he
played it very well up until getting
himself in time pressure and losing to a
blunder but still he looks like a
natural Sicilian player it's just
totally in his fingertips to play these
games
thank you Maurice and uh true to his
style Hikaru wasn't interested in just
trying to keep the position to fight
over the D4 square and he played the
active move F7 F6 you have to be careful
um in principal Black's King looks
really snug and fine in the middle of
board King E7 he's not being bothered by
anybody but after move like F6 sometimes
things can really open up in the center
of the board but F6 Knight D4 Knight
takes D4 for example a a a very bad
positional blunder would have been F
takes E5 when suddenly there's Knight
takes C6 Bishop takes C6 Knight takes E5
and we can see that white is fully
prepared to play F5 and blow up uh the
Central files and then the king could
find itself in deep trouble on E7 that
was why he Caro was first very careful
to play Knight takes D4 Knight takes D4
now trade and we have this position and
let me see if I'm up to
date am I up to date I thought he played
Bishop E8 Bishop E8 has been played yeah
so Rook takes F1 Rook takes F1 Bishop d8
stopping first of all H7 H6 right so
that you can move the Rook without
worrying about this Pawn on H7 and now
King F2 Rook H f8 King E3 King E3
bringing our King to the center of the
board now a rook exchange followed by
Bishop a to stop the type of idea like
Bishop G6 um
invading and also setting up for Knight
D7 so I would assume a move like G4 in
order to meet Knight D7 with Knight F3
in this case I don't have to worry you
about Bishop H5 you have Knight C6 mate
yeah better
still and much better is night6 that's
kind of a surprising mate right I didn't
see it coming not one bit but we had
some weird mates remember 8 in analysis
with the queen on B7 in the in the game
where he Caro
blundered oh yeah that was terrible oh
God pretty fun oh that was so painful
okay so at the moment I really like
White's position because frankly all of
his pieces have a little bit more scope
um more potency you might say in the
position and um not that clear we see an
interesting move by Karana he's played
the move Bishop H7 to Target uh the the
E6 Pawn from behind Bishop E7 Bishop H7
in order to play Bishop wow it looks
like a strange Invasion and kn7 um still
um not allowed because of KN C6 or not
advised not Nakamura really wants to
play a worse game than he did in the
second that is true so okay so to meet
Bishop G8 threat if I have to play
Bishop here then this check
could become actually pretty gruesome
the king cu the king is Marching In
indeed right King E8 and something like
this could actually work out really
really well I mean it's very rare to see
a king on D6 but look at that Suddenly
It's All She Wrote white has an absolute
positional Masterpiece uh great uh game
for for white here so but this maybe
this move Bishop H it looks like somehow
Nakamura is um Consolidated in a better
way than that so let's take a look at
how we arrange that okay I'll I'll
refresh my board and let's see what had
happened he's somehow gotten much better
than what what we just looked at so
after so chck King oh he didn't go maybe
there was some kind of problem with the
G6 and King f8 so you mean no King you
mean G6 here no I'm trying to figure out
how we could Poss he could just play
Knight D7 no just to stop the the the
coming in right okay but the way it's
been played it's beautiful what what
what uh those last moves with Bishop F7
by Carana Bishop F7 Knight C6 and then
King E8 Bishop D3 Rook C8 was played and
now Knight to B4 and Knight D7 going
after the E Pawn and now King to D4 and
look at this position the queenside
pawns are under heavy pressure how did
White just magically conjure up this
position with his Bishop H7 idea he has
better pieces everywhere better Rook
better Knight better Bishop better King
and certainly a better Pawn structure
well his Pawn sitting on E5 cramping the
position and Nakamura according to the
engine must now play the move Knight to
B8 wa you don't want to play Knight B8
but looks like Knight B8 is forced
allowing Knight takes on
A6 wow now ignoring that of course if
you take on A6 6 Bishop takes B5 check
and that's all she wrote with that fork
King and and Bish King and uh and Knight
but after Knight takes A6 the move
Knight C6 is possible with cck and King
C5 looks very enticing but apparently
King E7 is holding it up the engine's
like King back to E3 however and after
Knight takes E5 why can't I take yet
another Pawn suddenly trouble for black
even here though the engine saying it's
okayish well no much worse but not quite
a pawn which is surprising to me given
that he's up it looks like he's just up
a clear Pawn but it looks like this line
is unavoidable King to D4 every piece on
on the board by white is superior to
every piece for black and the bad Pawn
structure relative to the bishop and the
strong Pawn this is a big Edge guys this
is not close this is a big Edge for
white Nakamura is clearly on the
defensive and look at his body language
he is is showing it white just almost
miraculously has gotten this great Edge
in the position and Nakamura realizes it
yeah it just seems once again that
Hikaru uh who loves Dynamic play uh
played the move F7 F6 opening up the
position when he was not well enough
developed and uh White it's white who
took advantage of the open F line as we
saw with this move Bishop H7 very
intriguing move by the way and he has
found Knight
B8 uh Maurice mentioning that the
computer considered that the only move
in the position uh Knight B8 was played
and and now Faby having a chance to snap
a that's right snab upon meanwhile the
other game as we've become accustomed to
as they're fighting out in the end game
is uh barely past the opening St but
it's going to be with everything on the
board right yes and attacks gearing up
for both sides so we're going to see a a
sequel um we're seeing like all the
rocky series here as a Philadelphia girl
I got to get a reference to that because
I mean these battles between these two
and the Sicilian just are epic yes they
we just can hope that to see more of
them tomorrow and but what's happened
here so Bishop have six mooved now
though that's Maurice's favorite trade
Bishop takes Knight the bishop just
dropped back to uh E8 um opening up
opportunity for Rook takes c three what
happened after takes night now usually I
only want to do that if I have a really
good reason because I love my dark
squared Bishops and my Sicilians and for
both sides so you decided to take
capture capture and play G5 and now um
just as just as we talk about how this
game is going to be a a slugfest um it
simmers down quite considerably because
the Queens are coming off the board
exactly Bishop takes D4 probably
discression uh better part of valor here
and normally in sicil Sicilians where
you only have one weakness like the D6
Pawn when the king gets to E7 it's very
easy to defend I think that uh this
position is probably uh much closer to a
draw than an advantage for white yes
that trade of Bishop takes Knight in
that position is not one of those that
really highlights the advantage usually
it's an important trade if you're trying
to dominate the opposite color or you
get some initiative here there is no
initiative or at least any serious
initiative at D6 Pawn is going to be
very easy to defend I think she's happy
to consolidate her advantage of two
games after that excitement after
especially after last game don't get
crazy with this guy uh keep it calm and
be up to at the end of the day I think
that'll be great for her so she's
playing a riskless position something
that she's probably not going to lose
and there he goes playing King f8 and
preparing to bring his King to E7 on the
other hand the other game did go a
certain sequence but it looks like
Fabiano played the hyper aggressive line
that the computer did not like look at
this in this position after Knight takes
A6 Knight C6 check the engines liked
King back to E3 instead he played King
to C5 thinking he was going to sneak
into this Square possibly but now after
King to
E7 this king is starting to look a
little strange still it looks like he
could play maybe King takes B5 even King
B6 lots of moves here which one works
King takes B5 Knight takes E5 will be
playable and suddenly this bishop is
eyeballing this king from a different
angle and the engines are saying this
one is not that clear white with a
spinon of an edge but not that obvious
be because this king is not so clearly
good it looks like it should be but I
think primarily because this Rook is cut
off from the other pieces then black has
a preponderance of pieces that can
harass the white King on this side this
position not a serious Edge King
C5 again we talk about discretion being
the better part of valor King to E3 was
solid this one not so
much yeah this looks a little bit more
dicey I like being pawns up and look at
the change by the way in body language
and Nakamura now realizing that King C5
was an error and giving him a lot of
chances he realizes that was a mistake
exactly uh and on the other hand let's
let's see what whe whether uh Fabby has
blown it terribly or he still has uh
winning opportunity King takes B5 let's
say Knight takes yeah and let me do
something um well pass pawns must be
must be pushed what happens after D4 Jen
and he has taken on B5 by the way with
the king that's right King takes B5
Knight takes E5 we can pretty much
expect and now B4 okay so if I'm white
I'm saying hey look I'm going to just
you know escort my uh B Pawn up the
board I my intention is to go King A5 B5
and a away we go so let's try you've got
Bishop E8 checked you've got Knight
takes D3 KN Tak followed by Bishop G6
trying to get active in that way but I
guess you have Rook F3 there well in
that case I'm actually more happy to
meet Bishop G6 with Knight C5 and now
I've got my knight back in the game and
I still got these connect toids so I
would welcome that if I were white but
Rook C3 is the move to look at Rook C3
is the most active on the board right
Rook C3 hits the pawn on A3 it hits the
bishop and I wanted to go up the board
with A4
Bishop Bishop E8
check now I've got to go King if I want
to keep my a pawn which I do want to do
I Knight C6 Knight C6 check it's a
little if I
can if I can go through the currents
it's like white water rafting if I don't
hit a rock I'm going to play B5 and uh
I'll be fine you know what's funny going
back just one move no Bishop eek King
over if I could somehow what about Rook
C2 sweet I like it I like cuz KN C4 is
interesting that's a brilliant one I
like
it we love those checkmates that's a
that's a pretty one and we do have some
moves in the game in fact we got a king
B6 Bishop E8 on board okay so at this
moment when we left it King E7 had just
been played King takes B5 Knight takes
E5 King to
B6 uh that's another way of uh rafting
our way up the board and we have Bishop
E8
why do we like Bishop E8 I guess he's
setting up for Rook C6 check in some
variations what what makes that move
special Jen Bishop
E8 I'm I'm not sure I get it myself you
know the engines by the way now saying
that the positions basically equal and
maybe slight Edge for white A4 has been
placed now on the board but here's the
problem King to D6 and it was played by
Nakamura remember we were talking about
a moment ago every single one of white
pieces was better than every single one
of blacks you won't say that now I agree
now and and not this Rook looks like
it's most anemic piece on the board and
these guys are gang tackling this white
king at least that's the way it feels
you know Nakamura you're thinking a mate
is there a mate is there something weird
and although the engine saying it's
still fine don't worry about it White's
okay you've got to feel just a little
bit nervous with all these Che possible
Rook C6 check Knight D7 check is in the
position still he can capture here could
put a rook on C3 and the move the
engine's giving here goes one you won't
be happy with yes Rook to
A1 really serly that's the first choice
n no way in the world this move Rook A1
is a choice or Rook F2 or Rook D1 those
are the only moves it's giving don't
touch anything on this side this is
perfectly fine for black white has blown
it white has really blown it it's not
easy to advance anything and you've got
to be on the lookout for crazy threats
everywhere so it looks as though white
has completely messed up this game and
and Black's going to be fine and
Nakamura no doubt knows that as well
he's just he's just no just in the in
the blink of an night a king C5 move all
he had to do was just back up to E3 the
Carana but instead he played this
aggressive move overlooked King E7 and
the potential ramifications thereof and
now he's got nothing and he's nervous
you can see it in the way he just jerked
back in his chair to come back to say
what the heck is happening here what did
I do not now now not in you know usually
you like for him to just be thinking not
moving just every second you see his
body jerking every second there it means
he does not have a clear stream of
thought about this position at all not a
good case for him mean the other can I
make a blunder uh for yes I can I can
make a b how about rook f8 in the
Fabiano game you're mentioning that the
fact that my Rook is anemic and I'm
really dreaming I I'm dreaming that you
would Fork my king and Rook with Knight
D7 check I would go King B7 and if you
were to Rel trade Rooks I'd be super
happy because then my King's not getting
checkmated anymore so what's the
Tactical reputation for Rook f8 Maurice
uh there is no tactical reputation for
Rook f8 according to the engine actually
Rook f8 is playable uh in this
position that move is looks like it's
met by Knight takes D3 and E5 would be
the sequence but that looks like a good
choice Rook f8 would have been a a good
enough choice right now white still not
with the edge he wish wishes he had
instead he played Rook to F2 and black
has many choices for equality Knight to
D7 is the engine's first choice right
now so this move a very solid move by
caruana he's now under 5 minutes by the
way under 5 minutes at least on my clock
bit of a problem for him as well that's
a challenge there the other game we're
seeing this end game that is gotten
better for white over the last few moves
bit of a strange sequence that black did
to get to this position so this one
looking good for White and the engines
really like it as a matter of fact
although not enough to say you're
winning but man this is this is what you
dream of when you play this position
with the white pieces getting this weak
Pawn on D6 how the king go this way and
go back it was because of a rook H3 move
that cost him so she's playing very well
right now she wins this game and goes up
will it be plus three in the match M
he's going to have to go six 63 six
sorry not 63 62 to win the match and
five and a half two and a half to tie
the match he's got to have to completely
dominate her in Blitz in order to come
back and it's I don't see that happening
the way this is going right now so he
cannot afford to lose this game but you
know that last game guys that's the kind
of game that could just drive the steak
in the heart right boom it's such a such
such a feeling that you've you've lost a
one winning or one game and it can
really uh take the wind out of your
sales uh it's so hard uh but sometimes
you just got to forget a bad loss like
that last game well especially such a
well played game it certainly feels
feels sad to show a clinic in Sicilians
and then just throw it away with a
blunder one move yeah all right so we do
have King D6 where suddenly White's King
on B6 is looking very awkward uh and
checkmating threats in the position the
reason why I didn't want to play Rook F2
is I didn't want to see this move Bishop
C6 and ideas like Knight D7 check
appearing and I was afraid that my king
could really end up being in some kind
of a checkmating pattern so that was why
I went for Rook f8 but Rook F2 was
magnus's choice and he call Magnus fa
choice where did that come from Fabi
Choice Rook F2 and your wish list the
world championship future there you go
uh what are the actual clock times right
now Knight takes D3 after quite some
thought by the
way it seemed pretty even at the moment
that Knight takes D3 came with some
reluctance by hikaro but that was that
was odd and a poor choice the engines
are going nuts now saying D4 Bishop G6
D4 in response to this move yes and
white is back on top he he took he
traded off his most beautiful piece that
night for this response Bishop G6 but
after E4 the Knight it looks like the
White Knight will be able to get back to
C5 very comfortably the pawns will push
nice why did he play like this this
looks way inferior to his other choices
and the engines are saying yeah this is
good for white again that is that's
quite strange maybe he hallucinated and
was like looking at other variations
instead of D4 like KN B4 Rook B8 check
or well let's go with I'm sure uh Hikaru
had calculated D4 I'm sure he's
calculated
E5
takes takes Knight C5 I'm sure this was
all part of hikaru's calculations he's
putting a lot of stock on his
dwn uh hoping that that's going to give
him enough
counterplay for these two connected pass
pawns over there and looks like someone
Nei is it Nei in trouble in The Other
Board he's only has 16 seconds on the
clock oh my my
goodness again in heavy time pressure
just
manhandling uh
this just mishandling I should say being
manhandled mishandling this this time
situation and look at his Pawn structure
now that is about as ugly a pawn
structure as you're likely to see in a
sicilian and she's just calmly hunting
we're hunting wabbits here goes and he
has to play it looks like D5 because if
Rook D5 Rook B5 he's going to lose
material so he's just thrown down D5
trying to keep her out of D5 but is this
the is isn't this a pawn
unfortunately it may be far more than
just a pawn but uh the game as well Rook
takes D5 Rook takes D5 what else
takes uh King f8 what
else and by the way the E5 did happen in
the other game by Nakamura D4 and E5 did
happen but this looks lost yeah this
looks lost I was think thinking I can
play F6 takes takes King King King King
yeah this looks like the
simplest sorry F6 takes takes King King
D2 King here King here and I'm going to
run you out of moves with zuk Swang
aren't I or am I going to be zuk Swang
oh I think you just put yourself I put
myself in zuk Swang oh no I hate that so
meanwhile in the other game it looks
like a race of
Pawns yeah oh yeah oh C4 yeah yeah takes
takes King f8 and maybe just simply C4
F6 was an overreach in the
position takes
King King King and now aren't I in time
with my well maybe
not Dar it all right sorry I'm having a
little trouble just uh let's move over
to the line is definitely winning yes
definitely winning
it looks like the other game was a
mistake by Fabiano has now turned the
tables yet again unfortunately for him
he played B4 instead of A5 one Pawn push
difference we take a look here B4 should
not have been his choice Knight C5 is a
good choice A5 is a good choice but
trying to push both that's one of the
problems it happens often that it's hard
to push two pawns because one Pawn is
faster than two right and we see that
happen often and he tried to push both
of them at the same time what he should
have done is just get this one down the
board as fast as possible and freeze
this piece completely and then he could
start thinking about pushing the other
one instead he decided he needed this
one as well and the engine saying that's
not the best move because of D4 that's
all Nakamura can do in this position and
this one is going to end up on the D3
Square very fast it's all it's about
right now and it's not as easy to defend
this position Knight C5 is meant by Rook
to B8 with cck and what do you do to
defend this Pawn if you go back and
guard the pawn well this check looks
interesting for one but also King D5
bringing this King close and that's a
challenge he has instead played the move
B5 after B4 D4 he played
B5 and the engines now saying easy draw
well maybe not so easy but draw after
D3 this one looks very good for black
apparently although I'm terrified of
these pawns myself personally they look
pretty strong but the are saying this
this move is the key move he probably
has planned a knight move Knight B4
Knight C5 trying to slow this Pawn down
but the injuries are saying it's okay
for white it's okay for black excuse me
despite being a pawn down and these two
pass pawns wow what a crazy assessment
right now we'd have to get deeper into
it but I have the feeling that whatever
the engine says is not going to matter
because these players are going to be
deviating from Eng rules quite soon
thank you Maurice I I'm sure that when
Fabiana played the move B4 followed by
B5 it was int it was his intention to
play Knight B4 figuring that with this
Knight on B4 he was controlling the C2
Square he could you know if P push comes
to shove he can sacrifice his Knight and
then he was
thinking away we go with the a pawn but
I I think that he should have had played
A5 earlier and that now
after Knight B4 black has uh quite a
sufficient counterplay his his King's
going to be very active King D4 Knight
B4 King King D4 have been played Knight
B4 King D4 is very strong move just
bringing the you know sometimes uh your
King's just a very strong piece
especially the we've seen that again and
again in these matches haven't we and
you know with the idea of uh either King
E3 and D2 or King C3 and D2 and you got
to be wary sometimes there's even Rook
B8 check or something that can disturb
uh White from just pushing his Pawn up
the board the the problem though yes is
that now Knight C6 is playable and has
been played the engines preferred Bishop
to E4 trying to deal with this night uh
now Knight C6 on the board it's it's
slightly tricky for black still within I
would say the draw Zone but now he has
to play very accurate moves I don't see
him not playing the next two moves he
played King E3 Rook F3 check on the
board and now where to put the king if
you put it on E2 there's going to be
Knight D4 check and this Pawn looks very
fast by the way and King E2 is on the
board and the keep the only move to keep
any Edge right now is Knight to D4
according to the engine still not quite
a pawn for white as yet and he has
played Knight to e check and King to E1
King D2 is being touted as the best move
here and now Rook
G3 has been played and is winning
according to the engines Rook G3 is now
winning the game because Knight F3 will
always guard against this Pawn on the
Square and the bishop is hanging and
where do you put it on top of it this
bishop is going to get chased it looks
like Nakamura has AED King D2 was the
right move King to E1 is losing to Rook
G3 white is completely on top and the
other game was was just a simple Pawn
ending we can go into that pawn ending
yes your move that you talked about with
F6 was the killer blow and she just milk
that King and pawn you can show the
Finish there before we get to this other
one it looks like a very simple finish
the a A4 Pawn was going to decide and
after F6 uh she used her majority very
well and she hun takes a commanding
lead commanding lead now in the match
against ex but this game this ending
what a Miss by Hikaru I'm sure when he
is cool though it is a
really yeah because you know you're
you're dreaming of D2 but look at this
Knight F3 check takes this Pawn on D2
your Bishop on G6 is hanging and
suddenly that meant that um you can't
play D2 so a big swing going
here don't see that a lot no you don't
but tricky tricky time guys tricky time
King F2 King F2 is the engine move the
engine suggestion King F2 what do you do
after King F2 because you can't take the
bishop on G6 because of D2 just yet so
King F2 he has to find this as his
chance and then the Knight has to drop
back to B3 only move to keep an edge
only move Knight to B3 sorry the Knight
has to drop back and now it's under
control yet again as Rook to C3 doesn't
get the job done because after Rook
takes Rook takes and now now suddenly
this Pawn these two pawns this Rook can
sack for this one at any time so a rook
move like this one will do the job and
then uh hello there go those ponies
game's going to be over so one more
trick with King F2 but I think Nakamura
probably sees that Knight B3 is very
strong but there's nothing else
unfortunately for him to do maybe bishop
H5 to try to control this nope because a
rook takes so that's it yeah that's why
Rook G3 is so good G3 is awesome the
bishop moves you take the pawn on D3 and
then it's easy easy game exactly and if
you go back to H7 you lose the pawn on
G7 with the same tempo and then Rook E7
check as well and Nakamura sees it look
at his body language telling us the
whole story there he is he and he's now
under under a minute and under Fabiano
in the time 56 seconds for white 44
seconds for black and he's just sitting
up he doesn't know what to do right now
every move as his brain calculates
rapidly every one of them is losing he
is a little bit in panic mode now I
think Nakamura is not happy about how
today went and you know it and he's made
a move what has he played oh boy and he
is really he played Bishop to E4 and
allowed his Bishop to go Bishop to
E4 Rook E3 Rook E3 on the board and King
F1 and now after Rook takes
E4 um
D2 the the trouble is there's Rook F4
check
there's Knight
F5 I don't know what what moves we have
we'll see what we've got going on here
sorry I just Rook takes King F1 Rook
takes E4 has been played right and now
King F1 and now it's White's
move well Rook takes E4 D2 has been
played and now it's White's move and now
it's White's move right indeed and and
I'm expecting Knight F5 and Knight F5 is
it so I can Fork on E3 in case you
promote and if you don't promote I'm
about to play Rook D4 and that's all she
wrote and he found it Knight F5 very
good that's a PO blow that simplified
everything too because of that Rook D4
idea doesn't matter what you find now
because those two pass pawns are death
escorted by the king that is just pain
Nakamura has no moves what about Rook d8
Rook d8 only move Rook d8s only move and
let's push our Pawn
ah then maybe you can come back down
here with the Rook as o sorry I
shouldn't push my Pawn I'm going to have
to go 93 check it's still it's still
over here he's he's now got the Rook
behind we got something else instead
let's get the board position let's get
the board position let's get the big
board position he knows it and he has
resigned it's over the the pass pawns
combination plus The Rook a win for
Fabby wow what a day for him Nakamura
was quite pre in predicting his own
demise almost plus two on Fab's part for
the day gosh that around in the match I
mean confidence is such a powerful thing
in in chess and everything and maybe
maybe Nakamura shouldn't have said Faby
has a good chance of you pumped him up
pumped the really you think so well I'll
prove it I'll prove you're right yeah
one of the great things about nakamuro
is he always thinks he's going to win I
think you know he's got got that massive
amount of confidence which is so
important for an elad player in in every
field yeah in athletics you you really
need to have that mentality of this is
my sport exactly this is what I do this
is how I win but today Fabiana really
impressed uh scoring uh three out of
four I was really impressed by his
technique I mean obviously didn't play
perfectly all the time but I think
considering the circumstances
considering he's playing against the
trickiest player in the world right and
pretty fast time control at that a
trickiest player in the world at a fast
time control I thought his technique was
outstanding yeah a lot of good moves he
had a lot of good moves and it it really
was a narrow window there I think that
it once they got to this Ending by the
way I think that uh hikaro was right
that his gut instincts was were right
that the combination of Rook bishop and
pass Pawn was enough for uh draw wrong
counterplay but it's really remarkable
how narrow that window was and it was
right here this one bad move King
E1 that allowed this Rook uh G3 that's
great that's great and to be able to see
that opportunity too it's really tricky
in a one or two minute game with with a
10-second increment I think Fabiano
what's what's important for people at
home to realize is Fabiano makes it look
easy but it is not easy to make a bunch
of non blunders slash really of aome
moves for 30 moves in a row against
somebody like Nakamura exactly I mean
he's not used to people making so few
mistakes exactly and that's one of the
reasons why you see him playing G3 and
B3 he's thinking like hey my opponent's
going to make a mistake at some point
just play a non theoretical line and I
and I wait for my opponent to blender
yeah and that's not happening and so
Fabby actually this makes the match a
lot more exciting because we know
Nakamura is amazing blit player right
but U no guarantees of course taking the
lead now um via this 3-1 score in Rapid
chest he takes the match lead as well
and that's going to make it very
exciting tomorrow me well it basically
means H Caro cannot win the match by
just simply going with a 4 and 1 half
out of eight 4 and a half out of eight
plus one score he's going to have to
score five if he wants to win this match
five right he'll have to go plus two uh
and for Fabby is basically got draw odds
that's right and now um Nei vers uh yon
ne's got a tough task he's minus three
but luckily for him there are eight
games tomorrow so still Within Reach but
Ean uh playing very impressively indeed
exactly but she's playing good and she
got fortunate as well in that big big
big turnaround that's right so we do
have Perry Maran Nei now I know he might
be disappointed with the results today
but we do think that he played the most
awesome game of the match so true
there's always a silver lining he's with
Maurice Ashley indeed with one of
India's finest pan Nei student at
Stanford playing chess uh the first game
not so good the second game absolutely
beautiful game the one the one we
consider the game of the event so far
but then that third game that was just
incredible what were your thoughts
playing that game and then the way it
finished um I mean at some point I think
she should have repeated and then she
didn't and I thought I had just such a
nice position and I I begin to have
those like doubts because my position
looked so good and I like I want to find
a force way to win but then the time is
taking and um yeah I really like should
have just played moves because her
position was much harder to play and um
yeah yeah we talk about that in Blitz
all the time sometimes you have to find
the 75% move not the 100% perfect move
cuz that looking for that move could
cost you on the clock and it at one
point it seemed like you fritted away
about four minutes maybe looking for a
good move
oh it was it four minutes yeah I I
didn't even realize I mean I was ahead
on time and my position looked winning
so I thought like I should just finish
it off and I think that was a bad
strategy um I should have just played
moves kept ahead of on time and uh built
up the pressure instead then you know it
was like suddenly complicated I don't
know till what point I was winning but
then there was this like big shift and
yeah then it was made and it also looked
like you always had Perpetual if you
wanted it but you used were chasing that
win of course and you were still much
better I was Pro yeah I don't know if I
was winning or not you were still
winning yes you could have played Queen
H4 take on H4 and going into the end
game instead of instead of play Rook the
move you played which allow which
allowed Queen F4 there was just a moment
where you should have have kept that
yeah yeah I don't know why I didn't good
also y said you should have pushed the
Aon a long time ago what's the deal with
letting checkm still be in a position
yeah I really need to work on my Basics
you know backround just it little Center
um yeah I need those lessons again wow
uh clearly the last game as well looked
fairly even you would have thought you
could have drawn this position pretty
readily when she traded off Bishops and
went into this end game but uh maybe
yeah I think the the first and fourth
game both looked like dry or drawn end
games to me but then I was a little less
on time and she was like playing these
accurate moves um and I think again like
my time management was definitely bad
but like she found all these like little
ideas to like keep the tension and um I
just couldn't deal with u deal with like
the passiveness of the positions well
you're not talking about time management
tomorrow is Blitz and it's all about
time management you're down this many
points three points in the match mhm
what are you going to have to do to turn
the ship around um the good thing is I
can't poize if like I have nothing to
lose uh and that's I think a nice thing
in Blitz because the moment you start
stressing about the results like with
the time ticking it can be bad
um but uh I need better time management
I definitely need that well you can take
consolation in game two certainly the
Sterling game of the tournament of the
event so far we certainly enjoy watching
your enterprising play Everything a
sicilian we love it uh we hope to see
eight more Sicilians tomorrow thanks so
much grand masteri for entertaining us
and joining us after such tough tough
losses thanks always a gentleman always
with a smile panan and Nei you got to
root for the guy hopefully he manages
time better tomorrow thank you Maurice
thank you n he has some really fabulous
games there I was mentioning about how
much intensity and passion it's filled
in those Sicilian games it almost feels
like it's overflowing 15 minutes but can
you imagine having those types of games
in 3 minutes no wow I mean that's too
stressful that'll be a lot of fun for
spectators and uh commentators but for
the players themselves wow they'll
they'll have fun oh without question and
that's where you have to assume they're
not going to play perfectly I mean even
2700 players like these guys and they're
both very close to 2700 they're going to
make mistakes that's the nature of three
minute chat yeah and I think that's very
hard for a lot of grand Masters I think
a lot of grand Masters are really are
looking for truth in their games and
they are trying to find the perfect move
and when you do play these fast time
controls this um you don't want to
compromise you want to play the best
moves and sometimes it means that you're
really overthinking you should be be
playing but the but the truth is that
both both players are in the same
situation in the Sicilian it's tough for
both sides true and we've got a
Grandmaster hoan she's with Maurice
Ashley about another thrilling day for
her
fans well no one can say that she keeps
her fans bored that's for sure
Grandmaster ho you f here with me wow
What a Day first you win the first game
then you lose the second game in Crazy
spectacular style and then that third
game what were you thinking when you
decided not to repeat moves in a
position that just looked like time to
take a draw and get out of there yeah of
course and third game I'm almost losing
again you know and because you know um
my second game was uh just like okay I
got crashed all from the opening then I
felt a bit upset so I said probably it's
a time to not fight back about try to do
something you know but then the game of
course appeared in a reputation and I
should go for Queen que5 queen4 without
any doubts but then I just suddenly
decided why not try something else but
then I just go crazy old the again
incredible you played this M Night H4
the other thing is you had very little
time on the clock it's not as though you
had a big Edge on the clock and said
well let me see if he falls into time
pressure you already in deep time
pressure when you decided to to play
this move Knight H4 yeah maybe next time
I should be more you know not like more
irrational I should keep calm and try to
do something normal not like this
incredible and so what were you thinking
that then when you finally had this lost
position you're looking at and thinking
oh my goodness how am I going to survive
this were you were you desperate or just
making moves yeah it's it was short of
time but both of the players so I have
no time really to think how the position
was I just trying to make some moves and
continue the game not like resign
immediately okay it should be
immediately at some point for sure but
okay I'm just try to keep the game
continuing and after Queen F4 I still
think it's not good but anyway I
realized that she he cannot play ret one
so yeah it's more or less the only
chance nice little cheapos we like
tricks tricks are good tricks are not
just for kids uh so now you win that
game and then the last game it looked
like his heart wasn't in it because you
just got a nice position and he slowly
made some mistakes and and you got the
pressure you're able to win that game
yeah I think the last one came to a
normal way like the first game at least
and not like second and third game
probably Sicilian can bring oh actually
four games are all Sicilian yes it was
all Gam all open Sicilians are that just
now with 94 yeah but I think that the
second and third are real Sicilian
because it's a very
complicated yeah complete thrill so now
you're up three points in the match
going into eight Blitz Games what are
your thoughts going into the last day
wow
believe uh it's even unexpectable
compared to the rapper so I just hope
that as I can enjoy the format and the
all the spectators will enjoy that
that's enough are you planning to do
eight Sicilians tomorrow well probably
who
knows interesting that we played for
Sicilian today and uh yeah it seems like
both of us are very aggressive players C
really stubborn too walking right into
Sicilians well we really appreciate your
style and your fighting spirit thank you
so much for gracing us here at this
event and good luck tomorrow oh thank
you Grandmaster hoian wow we just we're
like this so nervous watching these
games can't imagine actually playing
them tremendous fights here at this
match between these two players thank
you Maurice and thank you who fun wow
Jennifer when you were uh coming up and
uh getting your Grandmaster title you
were you you enjoyed playing Blitz right
you played a lot of Blitz I yeah I
remember it's always fun to play we have
some Blitz session or two we played a
little Blitz with each other you're
pretty good I'm just wondering in the
women's game today do the women practice
Blitz oh yeah I think so maybe not as
much as guys though they they probably
they probably should more don't you
think well especially when you think
about the World Cup uh tournaments and
the fact that they are using uh faster
games as tie breaks you start with the
Rapids I understand and then you move to
rapid rapid and then to Blitz I don't
think it has anything to do with gender
Blitz I think everybody loves Blitz and
at some point in every player's career
Blitz is like a catalyst for them
getting even stronger I agree yeah if
anything maybe guys just um more
acceptable to like stay up really late
and like out till 4:00 just playing
Blitz Bug House you know okay so a
little bit sometimes a bit of a boy glub
we need yeah we need to start some girls
puts clubs
okay we've got a we got a special guest
uh who uh who uh won the rapid today
Grand Master Fabiano carolana um
defeating one of the best Blitz and
Rapid players in the world um 3-1
today yes we are with Grand Master
Fabiano Carana who we were talking about
lead changes and this match has shown it
all yesterday we saw him take the lead
only to blow it in the next two games
and and now today he's taking it back
yet again Fabby today's games you looked
very confident in your play maybe your
your strongest day to date of the three
days I think I was losing two games
pretty comfortably um so I wouldn't say
I was totally confident I mean both
black games I was outplayed out of the
opening and I managed to hold on but it
was it was pretty shaky uh and in the
second game I really can't explain why
he played F6 but I'm talk about it at
all this F6 move was looked just I mean
like we thought it may have been in some
kind of weird preparation did you think
that at the board as well for a few
seconds but then I decided to see what
kind of preparation it really is I mean
it's I knew that Queen D5 is the move I
knew this is all Theory and the F6 is
just not a move that's played so I you
know if I don't see a reputation of
Queen H5 I'm just going to go for it it
was really inexplicable to see a player
of that caliber play play this move do
you think maybe he had some other
preparation and something else and he
just mixed up this move um I'm not sure
maybe he he got confused with another
position thought that F6 is a move here
or maybe he just didn't see Queen H5 as
strange as that sounds I really don't
know he played it very quickly but and
then your the game you had with white
this last game it looked like you played
very well to a point and then all of a
sudden your king got in a bit of a mess
in the position what were your thoughts
when you realized that your advantage
seemed to have dissipated quickly it
looked very unclear after he played King
D6 but um I think Rook F2 was a good
move and uh my king looks shaky but it
somehow the Knight on E on A6 protects
everything and and the King actually
helps uh helps me advance my pawns so a
big day for you two wins two draws now
you're plus one he himself said that the
rapid was where is was going to be his
toughest challenge in in his mind you
two are numers two and three in the
world uh but Blitz it's a big difference
uh at least on the ratings he he out
rate You by over 200 points and he's a
number one rated blz player in the world
what do you have to do tomorrow to fight
off this monster uh I'm really not too
concerned I I think it'll be a very
close final day um I mean it could go
either way um but I have an advantage
going into it uh a one-point lead and uh
I mean maybe I didn't make the most of
my chances on the first two days and he
didn't make the most of his chances on
the uh today but um but I think that
it's uh it's been a very close match so
far and it will continue to be so in the
last day it's got to feel good being
plus one though going into the last
round yeah I'm very satisfied especially
since I was minus one before today well
good luck in tomorrow's game and
fighting off that Blitz monster you said
it's no big deal we just going to it no
it's it's not no big deal but I I'm
confident in my own skills there you go
as you should be Grandmaster Fabiano
caruana playing some great chess today
great Fighting Chess and we'll see what
happens as he takes a one one point lead
going into the last day you marce well
we said it's all about confidence right
Nakamura said 80% psychology so Carana
there you go confident about going in
tomorrow and we're excited because we
will have a great Showdown yes now I
think the way we're going to do it
tomorrow is we're going to stagger the
games so that only one game is going on
at a certain time so that we'll keep a
constant flow of games there'll be eight
games to eight points uh for
grabs in tomorrow's games that's right
so let's take a look at what we have
tomorrow it's the final day of the
showdown in St Louis it's eight rounds
of Blitz chest that's a 16 rounds in
total and it's going to be game three
with a 2C increment so it's going to be
wild it's going to be fun and we hope
that you're going to be joining us for
it it's going to be at 1250 Central
Standard Time It's 150 over in the east
coast and it's going to be the most
exciting matches that we have so far so
so lock it in and uh grandmas Mar asley
with some closing thoughts on today's
action well today was Topsy Turvy chess
of course that's what happens when you
play rapid chess it's funny to hear that
Karana say that he didn't play so well
today what are you talking about you
can't play precise moves there's no such
thing as a losing position in Rapid it's
always about psychology and time
management and he had plenty of both in
start in terms of confidence making sure
he didn't get too far behind on the
clock and he was able to overwhelm
Hikaru Nakamura don't get it wrong
Hikaru is a beast an incredible player
but today he did not show his finest
chess playing a move that he had he
would not play again probably for
another 10 years make a mistake on that
kind of level but it was very exciting
both matches tomorrow is going to be a
thrill I mean absolutely we've got to uh
be patting ourselves and pinching myself
for sure that I get this job a front row
seat at some of the most exciting chest
in the world I'm looking forward to it I
hope I see you guys here tomorrow thank
you Maurice absolutely for me I love the
front row seat that's right I can't wait
and uh thanks again to everybody here at
staff of the St Louis chess club World
Chess Hall of Fame Spectrum Studios and
fat chimp puts it all puts us all
together I'm Jennifer shahadi I'm
signing off for Grandmasters yaser San
and Maurice Ashley and we will see you
tomorrow for the conclusion of the
showdown in St Louis
[Music]